Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim und ich begrüße alle zur.
Dritten Ausgabe von UKW und nach zwei Wochen wollen wir mal wieder äh die Nachrichten zusammenfegen aus der Ukraine und äh ja, dafür begrüße ich natürlich Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Tatütata im äh Hintergrund. Ist auch gerade wieder auf Reisen. Ja, wir haben uns am.
12. September beziehungsweise am 12. September habe ich die letzte Sendung veröffentlicht und.
Das war dann unser vorläufiger Rückblick auf die Offensive der Ukraine in Rakief in dem Oblast-Rakive, wo.
Sehr schnell vorangekommen sind und man kann sagen, dass das äh schon ein wichtiges Ereignis gewesen ist, weil's im Prinzip die ganze.
Ja ganze Debatte um den Krieg, vor allem im Westen neu belebt hat und vor allem auch den Krieg selber äh
ja auf ein neues Gleis äh gesetzt hat. Wir werden heute sehr ausführlich, denke ich, über die Mobilisierung in Russland reden, die äh Putin jetzt angekündigt hat und die auch schon,
gonnen hat.
Trotzdem wollen wir natürlich äh vor allem auch mal ein bisschen ja beschreiben, was im Prinzip in den letzten zwei Wochen passiert ist, wie man sich dieses Geschehen insgesamt vorstellen muss.
Ähm einiges einiges auf der Liste.
Und wir haben dann äh hinterher auch äh
ja ich denke paar ganz interessante Rechnungen, äh wie's denn so weitergehen kann jetzt auch angesichts Mobilisierung und äh allem so da habe ich jetzt auch ein paar neue Erkenntnisse,
gewonnen seit der letzten Sendung.
Können wir erstmal so eine militärischen Gesamtsituation? Ich freue mich immer, äh inwiefern das eigentlich wirklich möglich ist, im Podcast, dass alles so,
richtig und plastisch auch darzustellen. Ich mir selber dabei zuschaue, wie ich versuche, dieses Kriegsgeschehen nachzuvollziehen,
unter Einsatz von sehr viel äh,
Material, was äh gepostet wird, aber was äh ich mir auch äh in Google Earth immer ausführlich anschaue, geprägt und grade mit den ganzen ähm,
Namen der ganzen
Orte ist das so seine Schwierigkeit, man kriegt da mal irgendwelche Orte genannt und dann ist es immer so die Schwierigkeit, okay in welcher Sprache ist das jetzt gerade geschrieben? Ist das jetzt die englische Transitration
des russischen äh des ukrainischen und äh außerdem stellt sich immer wieder heraus, dass es viele Ortsnamen äh in der Ukraine gleich,
hundertfach zu geben scheint. So ein bisschen wahrscheinlich wie ich hier so mit Neustadt oder so.
Also äh fangen wir an nach Niko Live oder sowas zu suchen, da wirst du äh richtig bekloppt oder Alexandriwer oder so, das scheint's äh hundertfach zu geben.
Na ja,
Trotzdem, man kann nach wie vor äh das Kriegsgeschehen, denke ich, im Wesentlichen in äh vier große Bereiche einteilen.
Da ist halt einerseits im Süden eben der Kampf um. Da haben wir ja hier schon ausführlich drüber gesprochen
diese knifflige Situation, wo die Russen,
westlich des äh sind und dort in gewisser Hinsicht eingeschlossen sind, weil äh Ukraine es gelungen ist, hier die Versorgungswege doch stark zu dezimieren beziehungsweise teilweise auch komplett zum
zu bringen. Da geht's weiter. Dann haben wir äh die.
Etwas östlichere Südfront äh auch bei diesem Kernkraftwerk, da,
Passiert gerade nicht besonders viel oder zumindest dringt davon nicht sehr viel nach außen. Dann gibt's natürlich den äh Kampf im Dornbars.
Vor allem da äh der Versuch der,
Russen bei Barboot voranzukommen, um dort halt die Strongholz der Ukraine anzugreifen, wo im Prinzip schon immer so die Kommandozentralen der Ukraine waren.
Seit zwanzig ähvierzehn, da kommen die Russen nicht so richtig voran,
natürlich dann die Region äh Rakiv beziehungsweise der Norden von äh Luhansk, das ist halt da, wo eben die letzte Offensive so viel Boden gut gemacht hat.
Ähm ja, vielleicht mal so in der Reihenfolge, also in ist jetzt nicht so viel Sichtbares passiert, also im Prinzip ist das dort immer noch diese selbe.
Nutzungskriegsführung, sprich die Ukraine tastet sich hier und da langsam vor, hat insgesamt aber äh,
die Initiative in der Hand, wie auch eigentlich sonst überall mittlerweile im Kampfgebiet.
Ähm das heißt, hier gibt's äh einzelne Scharmützel und äh versuche halt voranzukommen. Es sind halt
sehr viele russische Truppen dort stationiert, deswegen ist der Widerstand dort auch äh groß. Aber wie gesagt, da haben die Russen im Wesentlichen damit zu kämpfen, ähm.
Die Versorgung sicherzustellen und das dürfte ihnen in zunehmendem Maße schwerfallen. Ich habe so den Eindruck, dass dort,
militärisch eben nicht groß gedrückt wird, weil die Schwerpunkte derzeit woanders liegen, also von der aus der Perspektive der Ukraine heraus.
Trotzdem natürlich wichtig dort äh Fortschritte zu erzielen und ich vermute, dass die Ukraine schonenden Zeitplan dort im Kopf hat, wie sie äh vorgehen möchte.
Aber das hast natürlich einerseits von den Vorgängen im Rest des Landes abhängt, wie sie den äh Kräfte mobilisieren können,
wie sie auch selber die Stärke der Russen dort so bewerten und haben im Wesentlichen ihren Blick auf die Brücken und ballern halt auch immer wieder diese Brücken am Kinderpaar, um halt möglichst zu verhindern, dass die Russen sich dort verstärken können.
Ja. Ich habe von, sagen wir mal, von zwei Seiten auch noch ähm gehört,
wohl das russische Militär ähm lieber sich dort zurückgezogen,
hätte äh und seine Position konsolidiert, dass aber wohl Putin gesagt haben soll, nein, ihr bleibt äh so auf der anderen Seite und äh zieht euch nicht zurück.
Ja, das ist so eine so so eine fortwährende Diskussion darüber, wie sehr mischt sich Putin eigentlich direkt ein und es gibt eine ganze Menge Berichte, die sagen, er mischt sich extrem ein.
Also militärktisch nicht besonders klug äh klingt, weil er natürlich politische Ziele hat.
Und äh in irgendeiner Form meint, er müsse die einfach durch Direktanweisung umsetzen, wie zum Beispiel ihr zieht euch da nicht zurück.
Ob das dann aber so klug ist, das weiß ich äh äh nicht. Also das macht zumindest nicht so den Eindruck.
Hat dann aber auch zur Folge, dass dann eben auch in zunehmenden Maße.
Wie soll ich sagen, ja nicht unbedingt Militär strategisch, sondern eher so terroristisch zugeschlagen wird. In der Gegend,
gab es zum Beispiel jetzt den Fall, dass die Russen mit äh Miss Hals, den,
In, oh je und jetzt wird's richtig lustig, also schreiben tut sich das so, dass man sagen würde, Griviri.
Aber ich habe äh versucht rauszufinden, wie sich das richtig ausspricht und das ist wohl Rock.
Keine Ahnung, was es auch immer ist. Auf jeden Fall handelt es sich dabei um eine äh.
Eine kleinere Stadt im Nordosten dieses Kampfgebiets, also was hinter der Frontlinie liegt.
Noch mal ein paar Kilometer und es ist interessanterweise Selinskies Heimatstadt.
Und ähm dort staut sich dieser äh Fluss, das ist so ein kleinerer Fluss, der von Norden nach Süden fließt mitten durch dieses Kampfgebiet durch und dort äh unten in den,
mündet und das ist auch so ein.
Strategisch sehr wichtiger und umkämpfter Bereich, wo es den Ukrainern gelungen ist, an verschiedenen Stellen auf die andere Seite zu gelingen, aber auch sehr viele Positionen am Fluss hat.
Ja und dann äh mit Misshalt haben sie also diesen Damm angegriffen. Konkret haben sie nicht den Damm selber angegriffen, sondern so ein,
Ablaufbereich, wo also so Verschlusstore sind, die sind zerstört worden, also bis 1 davon
und dann ist natürlich entsprechend viel Wasser aus diesem 31 Quadratkilometer großen Reservoir in den Fluss geflossen, hat natürlich dazu geführt, dass im,
Häuser dann überschwemmt wurden, die da unmittelbar dran waren, aber so die ganz große Katastrophe ist es dann glücklicherweise nicht geworden.
Auch wenn es für die Stadt natürlich ein Problem ist und äh auch für eine gewisse Wasserknappheit wohl äh gesorgt hat, zumindest für einen bestimmten Zeitraum. Ich habe jetzt zuletzt relativ wenig dadrüber gehört. Daraus schließe ich, dass sie das Problem so ein bisschen in Griff bekommen haben.
Die Strategie dahinter, abgesehen davon, dass es natürlich so wieder so zerstörend in ziviler Infrastruktur ist und damit so eine so eine Terrorstrategie, die wir ja überall sehen von den Russen in der Ukraine.
Kann ihre Kalkulation gewesen sein, dass eben diese Überflutung des Flusses wiederum stromabwärts dazu führt, dass äh es den ukrainischen Truppen schwer gemacht wird, diesen Innovlets äh Fluss zu passieren, aber.
Das hat wohl zu Problemen geführt, aber dass es so nennenswerte Auswirkungen gehabt hat, davon habe ich jetzt relativ wenig äh gehört.
Das Gute daran ist, dadurch, dass es nur eben diese Dammtore sind, die zerstört wurden, die.
Also jetzt nicht das gesamte Staubecken ab, sondern dass es eben so ein Bereich, wo nur so die oberen fünf Meter abfließen können.
Und ähm na ja ich habe so die Einschätzung gelesen, dass so drei Tage bis zwei Wochen dauern.
Kann bis bis das Wasser dann sozusagen abgeflossen ist, wenn sie's nicht irgendwie ähm gestopft bekommen. Das Problem scheint.
Weitgehend im Griff zu haben zu sein, so ne? Sind wohl so ein paar Ponton-Brücken dann von der Ukraine mitgerissen wurden. Also es hat irgendeine Auswirkung gehabt, aber im Wesentlichen ist einfach die Gegenwehr der Russen doch.
Relativ äh wie soll ich sagen, ungerichtet und und verzweifelt hat man so den Eindruck.
Andererseits haben sie versucht eine dieser beiden Brücken über den äh irgendwie zu fixen. Da gibt es ja diese eine große Brücke, die Antonowski-Brücke, die ja.
So weit zerstört wurde, dass sie eben für schweres Gerät nicht mehr verwendet werden kann.
Die andere Brücke ist ja auch wiederum an einem Staudamm, da ist die zerstörte Brücke eigentlich nur ein sehr kurzer Bereich, also so quasi mehr nur dieser Schleusenbeckenbereich, mit dem man an diesem Damm vorbeifahren kann.
Äh die Russen mittlerweile einfach mit Schutt aufgefüllt, um darüber zu kommen. Da wird aber weiterhin bombardiert, also dass es da auch Katz und Maus und ich habe so den Eindruck, äh wenn sie da Fortschritte machen, dann keine großen Fortschritte.
Mehr lässt sich jetzt eigentlich zu dem Kampf in dem Gebiet nicht nicht sagen und ich habe so den Eindruck, das könnte auch nochmal zwei Wochen dauern.
Wir nähern uns ja jetzt dem Herbst, dass äh ändert unter Umständen noch mal die Parameter, aber bisher gibt's da einfach nicht sehr viel zu zu sagen.
Insgesamt waren vielleicht dann auch noch feststellen, dass ja die Ukraine,
leichte Fortschritte gemacht hat, also kleinere Geländegewinne ähm so nichts Spektakuläres, aber äh ja
äh doch ich sage mal die Russen äh eher langsam äh sich sich auch zurückziehen oder zurückziehen mussten, so aber das sind dann so hunderte von Metern am Tag oder,
in der Größenordnung ein halber Kilometer am Tag, der da um den sich die Front verschiebt.
Militärstrategisch wird oft gesagt, dass es sich dabei um Shaping Operations handelt, also man versucht quasi das Schlachtfeld so in die,
Position zu bringen, wie man's gebrauchen kann,
Versorgungsrouten Munitionslager weghauen, Command und Controlposten wegballern. Dann gab's auch so diverse Partisanen Aktionen, wo so ähm.
Ja aus der Perspektive der Ukraine verräter äh sozusagen,
explizit angegriffen wurden, Autos äh in die Luft geflogen sind mit Leuten, die halt mit äh den Russen zusammenarbeiten. Alles so,
kleine Operationen hier und kleine Operationen da und ich wäre aber auch nicht so überrascht
zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt ähnlich wie in hier irgendwann nochmal so die Initiative sich auf einen bestimmten Bereich konzentriert in dem Moment, wo Ukraine einfach die,
Möglichkeit dazu sieht und dann kann es sich da auch sehr schnell wandeln.
Oder die Lieferung von Winterklamotten, die ohnehin schon sehr wohl spärlich äh äh läuft äh so äh zu behindern äh und äh sodass die Russen dann frieren in ihren Stellungen.
Das kommt noch dazu. Ja und dann kommen wir zur ähm Rakifik-Offensive.
Hier in der letzten Sendung ausführlich beleuchtet, wie das dort vorangegangen ist. Es endete ja letzten Endes mit der Besetzung oder.
Befreiung kann man sagen, von äh,
so eine ganz äh wichtige Stadt ist, weil es dort extreme russische Truppen und Gerätekonzentrationen gab. Da ist ja enorm viel Material in die Hände der Ukraine gefallen und ich glaube, die finden jetzt immer noch äh neue Lager mit Panzern und äh anderem Gerät.
Mittlerweile führt also Russland äh die Liste der Länder, die am meisten Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine gemacht haben bei weitem an dadurch.
Ja, es befand sich dort ja auch das Hauptquartier äh von weiten Teilen der der Front. So, das war ja äh da gab's ja auch dann unter anderem einen
an diesen spektakulären Schlag auf ein Hauptquartier, wo dann irgendwo wohl bis zu 100 russische Offiziere getötet worden sein soll.
Ein paar Monaten.
Also die Ergebnisse dieser ersten Welle sind jetzt also offensichtlich unheimlich viel Kriegsgerät, vor allem auch,
Wenn ich tausende von Kriegsgefangenen, die dort gemacht wurden, die natürlich die Ukraine jetzt nutzen kann, um,
gegen ähm ja eigene Soldaten auszutauschen. Es gab ja eine spektakulären Gefangenenaustausch. Da können wir vielleicht später noch zu.
Ähm,
Viele Kollaborateure sind dort äh gefangen genommen worden. Auch diese Lehrer, die die Russland dorthin geschickt hat, um den Schülern zu erzählen, wie schön die russische Welt ist. Alles keine guten,
Zeichen für den Rest der Region. Da äh gab's extreme Fluchtbewegungen und dürfte jetzt die Pläne der Russen ähm,
diese Territorien nicht nur einzunehmen, sondern eben auch aus ihrer Perspektive zu russifizieren, dann doch äh stark einschränken.
Und ähm ja was es danach passiert, also nach diesen schnellen Vorstößen mussten natürlich jetzt die ukrainischen Truppen erstmal konsolidieren. Also sie müssen erstmal.
Gerät nachziehen, Personen nachziehen. Sie müssen natürlich auch in den ganzen Ortschaften äh präsent werden, dort den Leuten helfen, äh nicht wahr, also einfach
dafür sorgen, dass dort wieder äh Nahrung und Trinkwasser vorhanden ist et cetera, also das zieht ja dann auch einen riesigen logistischen ähm.
Rattenschwanz nach sich.
Postdienst, Mobilfunknetz.
Genau, also überhaupt Strom, äh Infrastruktur, all das wiederherzustellen, inwiefern das jetzt im Einzelnen schon überall wiederhergestellt ist, das weiß ich nicht, aber
Grundsätzlich muss es natürlich vor allem erstmal militärisch abgesichert werden, um einfach
entsprechenden Vorstößen, zum Beispiel von der russischen Grenze aus äh in irgendeiner Form etwas entgegensetzen zu können und das kann man halt nicht mit den Truppen machen, die da jetzt äh
gerade eine Woche lang äh an der Front voran marschiert sind. Also hat man sich an diesem Osthilfluss erstmal ähm.
Festgesetzt, aber auch gleich die Offensive weiter nach Osten,
weiter getrieben und sind wohl relativ schnell gelungen, insbesondere dieser strategisch wichtigen Stadt von,
dort auf die andere Seite des Flusses zu gelangen, auch wenn da wieder Brücken zerstört wurden und teilweise eben dieser Fluss übertreten auch nicht so einfach macht, auch wenn der jetzt nicht so tief ist wie andere Flüsse.
Ja und ähm das führte schon dazu, dass sie eben diverse Brückenköpfe haben, installieren können, also wo sie quasi mit ihren Truppen und Gerät
der anderen Seite des Flusses waren, ohne jetzt gleich voran zu äh schreiten. Und das Ganze
geschehen hat, sich dann sehr an den Süden äh hin orientiert, weil dort beginnt im Prinzip jetzt gerade die Schlacht um,
Die nächste, wichtige, strategisch wichtige Stadt, das ist nämlich Lyman,
ein ganz wichtiger Verkehrsknotenpunkt für die Eisenbahnlinien.
Und auch ein Ort mit erheblicher russischer Truppenpräsenz.
Wird im Prinzip von mehreren Seiten her jetzt äh eingekreist äh finden dort auch Kämpfe statt, aber viel interessanter ist, dass es wohl,
der Ukraine jetzt gelungen ist, sich so untenrum äh,
Süden her auf diese andere Seite des Osthilf Flusses, der so im Nord-Süden verläuft ähm rumzuschwänzeln und dort,
wiederum so ein Brückenkopf so weit voranzutreiben, dass sie dort äh derzeit erhebliche Geländegewinne machen. Das geht jetzt nicht so schnell wie vor zwei Wochen,
vor drei Wochen aber ähm man sieht, dass dort doch eine ganze Menge passiert
insgesamt scheint die also die Operational Security der Ukraine sehr gut zu funktionieren während diese Vorstöße stattfinden.
Relativ wenig an bestätigten Informationen raus und dann irgendwann mal wieder so, ach ja, das äh Örtchen haben wir jetzt auch noch, das Örtchen haben wir jetzt auch noch und es macht gerade so den Eindruck, als könnte es der Ukraine gelingen
wichtigen Ort Lyman dann eben auch von Norden her einzukreisen und dann hätte man wieder so eine ähnliche Situation wie Isium.
Wo also dieser russische Strong Hold hm soweit
eingekreist ist und vor allem auch von seinen Versorgungslinien abgeschnitten wird,
dass äh am Ende den Russen dort auch nicht sehr viel übrig bleiben wird als ja fluchtartig,
alles wieder nach Osten zu verlassen und ich würde sagen,
es der Ukraine gelingt in Lüman nochmal das zu wiederholen, was sie in Issimen jetzt schon äh getan haben, das wird äh nicht gut äh ankommen.
In der russischen Veröffentlichkeit und wohl schon gar nicht immer Militär.
Wobei,
sich das sagen um um jetzt auch mindestens seit einer Woche äh hinzieht äh der der Vormarsch angeblich äh sollen auch teilweise Russen,
gezogen äh äh worden sein äh dort und angeblich die Verteidigung jetzt dann vor allem in den Händen ja von äh einheimischen Truppen.
Liegen, also von ja LNR, DNR Höre und so. Gut,
weiß man nicht so genau, aber äh das meldet zumindest die Gerüchteküche und das eben hat es ja auch angedeutet, dass mittlerweile auch in Liman selbst gekämpft.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall ähm derzeit dort der äh Stand und man kann halt nur abwarten,
jetzt hier äh vorangeht, aber ich habe so den Eindruck, dass wir, wenn wir hier zur nächsten Sendung treffen, dort wieder,
einiges passiert sein wird, ne
insgesamt ja waren das einfach schon mal sehr wichtige äh Schritte und sollte es halt jetzt gelingen auch noch Lühman und dann vielleicht eben auch noch die angrenzenden Gebiete da wo
vor Monaten so finster gekämpft wurde. Also Lucy Chansk und hier wäre und so diese Gebiete auch noch ähm in Bedrohung zu bringen, dann würde ich sagen
das Ganze das Potenzial hier wirklich auch ähm die gesamte russische,
Offensive, die mittlerweile eigentlich mehr so eine Defensive ist, komplett ins Schwanken zu bringen. Also das sieht äh überhaupt nicht gut aus für die Russen und ähm,
Am Ende äh könnte es darauf hinauslaufen, dass sie sich vielleicht im wieder auf die Grenzen vom 24. Februar zurückziehen müssen.
Die einzige wirklich gut ausgebaute Verteidigungslinie ist die sie dann eben auch gut halten könnten für absehbare Zeit,
aber wie schon letztes Mal,
vermutet hatte, ich sehe nach wie vor einen starken Vorstoß auf diesen ganzen Norden von Luhansk und wenn ähm das so weitergeht, wie es da derzeit äh weitergeht, dann wird das auch noch in diesem Jahr stattfinden.
Also das ist so bisschen die
die Gesamtsituation, wie gesagt, die äh Ukraine wird eine Menge damit zu tun haben, allein erstmal das ganze Gerät, was sie dort erbeutet haben.
Fit zu machen, also da wird bestimmt gerade eine ganze Menge geschraubt und und und repariert. Die Größenordnung,
Da gibt's halt nur so so Schätzungen, ne, also sie müssen es ja auch noch, das ist ja auch so ein Aspekt, wenn ich noch gar nicht erwähnt, muss man sich mal klar machen. Sie haben also diese riesigen Geländegewinne gemacht, aber
bevor sie dort eben sich auch wieder frei bewegen können, wo auch die Bewohner sich halbwegs frei bewegen können, muss das ja auch alles ähm
von Minen befreit werden. Und ich glaube bisher haben sie schon über 12.000 Minen entschärft
und da gibt's sicherlich nochmal äh eine ganze Menge mehr, weil sie da grad mal nur,
ja Bruchteil des Gebietes überhaupt erst haben absuchen können.
1 Prozent zu größenordnungsmäßig.
Genau, das dauert. Na ja ähm.
So viel vielleicht zur zur militärischen äh Situation gibt uns vielleicht auch nochmal kurz Gelegenheit eine Frage, äh die du auch schon in den Kommentaren beantwortet hast aus äh dem Feedback nochmal.
Reinzuwerfen, die glaube ich ja.
Insofern eine einfache und gute Frage ist, weil es so Gedanken sind, die man schnell kriegen kann. Äh Maka fragte, äh ja, wieso schneidet die Ukraine nicht einfach alle Wege aus Russland ab.
Funktionieren die Eisenbahnlinien aus Russland noch? Ähm stimmt jetzt im Fall von Rakief nicht mehr, weil er mit sozusagen das ja auch,
äh wurde, aber es gibt ja auch noch weitere Eisenbahn äh Linien, wieso existiert die Krimbrücke noch?
Äh erstelle sich das doch oder sie äh stellt sich das auch technisch nicht so schwierig vor, einen Zug mit brisanter Ladung aufs Gleis äh zu setzen und ähm irgendwo
explodieren zu lassen, ähm damit das Gleis äh vernichtet ist so.
Ja mein der Punkt ist natürlich passiert es zum Teil,
so, aber ähm wie wir's auch schon aus dem zweiten Weltkrieg äh kennen, ähm so hm so Eisenbahn.
Wenn man die zerstört, strecken normalerweise, wenn's nicht grade irgendwie eine eine große Brücke ist oder so
dann sind die relativ schnell wieder herzustellen. Da hat man nie so in ein, zwei Tagen repariert und selbst auch wenn's kleine Brücken äh sind. Das heißt,
Sie sind na das ist zum einen.
Nicht einfach äh dort Zerstörung anzurichten und vor allem äh äh schwierig halt nachhaltige Zerstörung anzurichten. Da lohnt es sich dann mehr.
Äh jetzt tatsächlich dann Züge beladene Züge anzugreifen beispielsweise oder Hauptquartiere oder.
Lager zu vernichten, äh die man die man hat so und ähm.
Der äh Kersch- äh Brücke, das ist nochmal.
Also die Brücke zwischen der Krim und Russland.
Genau. Ähm abgesehen davon, dass das eine ziemlich massive Brücke ist und die nicht so einfach kaputt zu kriegen ist jedenfalls nicht mit dem.
Die Ukraine hat an ähm Waffen hm ist die halt auch äh durch Luftabwehr ganz gut gesichert und sie haben,
daneben auch noch mal so Radartäuschkörper, die äh damit.
Irgendwelche Raketen, die sich dann im Endanflug am Ralabild orientieren halt äh nicht so gut matching machen können und dann halt auch stattdessen quasi so eine,
pseudobrücke aus Radar-Reflektoren äh im im Wasser treffen und ja und.
Irgendwie Boten dahin zu kommen, es sagen auch fast ausgeschlossen, weil ähm ja dort natürlich auch entsprechend.
Russisches Militär äh patrouilliert. Also er müsste dann Deutschland schon U-Boote liefern vielleicht.
Dann äh wäre das.
Bestimmt.
Ja ja Deutschland, ich meine eigentlich auch ein äh drüber äh wird's eine Rede von Panzern, aber tatsächlich ist Deutschland ja Weltmarktführer bei U-Booten.
Also die also die Hälfte aller Länder hat irgendwie mindestens ein deutsches U-Boot. Also die Hälfte der Länder, die U-Boote überhaupt haben, hat äh.
Mindestens ein deutsches U-Boot. Und äh ja, die sind also eigentlich die echten Exportschlager.
Na gut, aber derzeit äh hat die Ukraine keinen keine Navy, weil die hat ihn ja Russland in der Krümm geklaut.
Aber wer noch Eskalationspotential zu sagen irgendwie,
Panzer, wir liefern jetzt gleich U-Boote. Ich meine, das das wäre halt dann äh einfach mal sozusagen auch PR-technisch mal einen einen Coup, um zu zeigen, hm,
dass Deutschland äh halt dann die Ukraine mehr unterstützt als alle anderen.
Da gibt's auch noch viele andere Gelegenheiten, aber äh.
Die werden derzeit leider äh nicht genutzt, ne. Äh in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht noch zwei Anmerkungen. Also einerseits sieht man das ja auch
an dieser Antonowski-Brücke. Ne, also in die große äh Brücke bei der Stadtresson, die halt einfach dort Nord-Süden ähm die den Teneppa überspannt, äh sehr breit ist, also
sagen wir mal vergleichbar zu dieser Meeres ähm Querung der Krim,
da äh greift die Ukraine jetzt seit Wochen mit diesen Haimas-Raketen an, die also so hoch
präzise sind, die also ihr ihr Ziel auf wenige Meter genau treffen können und äh es gibt, weiß ich nicht, mindestens Berichte von zwölf bis fünfzehn
Bombenattacken auf diese Brücke.
Und es gibt ja auch Fotos davon, was dann sozusagen davon übrig gegangen ist und das ist halt nicht so, dass man die dann immer einmal trifft und dann ist die Brücke im Arsch, sondern da sind dann halt so Löcher im Boden.
So von ein, zwei Meter Durchmesser vielleicht.
Die sind ziemlich durchlöchert und es gibt auch historisch immer ganz, ganz viele spektakuläre Beispiele, wo irgendwie sowohl auch im Zweiten Weltkrieg die,
Alliierten, wie auch dann Deutschland versucht haben, irgendwelche Brücken äh dann aus der Ferne zu treffen. Äh ich glaube um den.
Vormarsch äh dann äh glaube.
Dass die Brücke von von Arnheim äh eine der Rheinbrücken jedenfalls hat Deutschland dann auch, ich weiß nicht, vierzig V zwei Raketen abgefeuert auf diese Brücke mit äh kaum,
Erfolg äh zum Beispiel und äh dann auch sich,
in in anderen Ländern, wo die wo die USA dann, ich weiß nicht, äh die Alliierten dann 30 Bombenmissionen äh gemacht haben und die Brücke äh immer noch stand danach.
Ist schwierig.
Brücken sind halt dafür gebaut, dass da über Jahrzehnte schweres Gerät rüber äh kachelt, da es muss schon eine gewisse Strukturfestigkeit haben und die kriegt man halt nicht mal eben mit so einer Explosion aus der Ferne hin. Klar, wenn man da irgendwie tagelang Zeit hat äh Spezial
Explosionsstoff an den kritischen Stellen zu
montieren und dann in einer gezielten Operation das Ding äh abzusprengen. Okay, das ist was anderes, aber das kriegt man eben aus der Ferne so nicht hin.
Andererseits ist es ja auch so.
Dass eben bestimmte Schwächerungen äh gegebenenfalls auch schnell wieder hergestellt werden können. Also es gibt zahlreiche Eisenbahnbrücken aus.
Wo die Ukraine, die selber gesprengt hat oder wo die Russen die äh gesprengt haben, die sie dann wieder hergestellt haben, als sie eben dieses Gebiet dann wieder unter Kontrolle hatten. Das geht dann schon relativ schnell,
Und ein Faktor, ähm auf den ich gestoßen bin, ist wohl, dass die Ukraine für solche Fälle.
Jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr bei Eisenbahnbrücken, das weiß ich jetzt nicht, sondern generell bei Brücken.
Vorgesorgt hat, indem sie in großen Mengen vorgefertigte Betonteile produziert haben.
Das ist wohl etwas, was äh die Russen überhaupt nicht getan haben.
Und ähm weil da auch irgendwie die Fähigkeiten zu führen, zu fehlen, weil sie im Detail jetzt nicht auf jeden Fall äh ist es offensichtlich so, dass sie äh da keine entsprechenden Reserven haben, aber die Ukraine sehr wohl
Zweisfall, wenn die halt wieder eine Brücke herstellen müssen, dann können sie eben
mit Spezialtransporten so große betonfertige, vorgefertigte Betonteile rankarren, mit denen sie dann eben sowas äh überbrücken können.
Bei der Grimmbrücke vielleicht als letztes kommt noch hinzu, dass es jetzt hier in Wirklichkeit um drei unabhängige Brücken handelt, mehr oder weniger.
Äh weil die die natürlich schon auch gebaut haben mit der Überlegung im Hinterkopf, dass vielleicht,
die Ukraine oder sonst irgendjemand auf die Idee kommen könnte
diese Brücke anzugreifen und deswegen ist da auch ein gewisses Maß an an Redundanz, also eigentlich müsste man quasi drei unabhängige Brücken, also die Zugbrücke und,
zwei äh Richtungsfahrbahnen, die jeweils auch auf völlig eigenen Pfeilern äh stehen, dann zerstören um die sie wirklich zu unterbrechen. Und,
Politisch ist es natürlich auch äh,
so, dass man überlegt, dass man vielleicht äh für alle Fälle den Russen auch eine Rückzugsmöglichkeit äh lassen möchte oder erst mal gucken, dass wenn es dort zum Konflikt,
bekommt, dass dann erstmal möglichst viele äh Russen dann dort die Krim verlassen.
Genau, also die,
Eisenbahnbrücke, das wäre sicherlich ein Wert des Ziel und ich denke, wenn Sie die Möglichkeit hätten, die wegzukloppen, das würden Sie dann schon tun, aber da müssten Sie halt auch schon sehr genau zielen, dazu bräuchten Sie also
diese Spezialmunition, die die Amerikaner ja bisher noch nicht bereit sind zu liefern diese Attacke äh MS.
Ähm Munition, die man äh in den selben Lohnschaden starten kann wie derzeit diese Haimas, also diese Haimas Loungeer, die also derzeit nur mit dieser vierzig bis was das 50 Kilometer Range.
Bis heißt ausgestattet sind und.
80 okay, aber man man könnte eben auch noch die dicke Fette reinmachen. Da hat man dann nicht sechs drin, sondern nur eine
Ja die äh abgeschossen wird, die in sehr viel größeren Sprengkopf ähm hat und die vor allem irgendwie 2hundertfünfzig Kilometer fliegen kann und äh so richtig Alarm macht so, aber aus ja politischen Gründen ist es.
Ja, nicht nur aus politischen, äh sondern es ist gibt auch noch so ein paar andere Probleme mit irgendwie.
MS, abgesehen davon, dass die auch deutlich teurer sind, also irgendwie ungefähr 800.000 Dollar äh pro Stück kosten. Ähm.
Und man eben damit dann nur ein Ziel bekämpfen kann.
Während man eben mit den äh GMLRS äh System halt sechs unabhängige Ziele äh äh bekämpfen kann und dann äh sind halt diese GMLS äh Systeme wohl,
etwas präziser als die Attackems, das heißt, das spielt auch nochmal.
Keine unerhebliche äh Rolle und natürlich jetzt generell ist eben auch die Aufklärung äh,
schwieriger, wenn du halt jetzt genau 300 Kilometer äh hinter der Front treffen willst, ist es nicht unbedingt einfacher. Ähm.
Ja oder schwieriger. Es ist halt schwieriger das Ganze aufzuklären. Wobei.
Ähm diese äh Attackems äh Container haben halt äh oben wohl so Verschlusskappen.
Die äh,
es nicht leicht machen zu unterscheiden. Also die die sind sozusagen als Gmilla S Systeme getarnt. Das heißt du kannst äh die wohl,
ohne Weiteres äh äh unterscheiden, bevor die nicht abgefeuert äh worden sind.
An alles gedacht. Genau. Soviel dazu.
So dann äh ist aber politisch eine ganze Menge äh passiert. Zunächst einmal äh wurde dann von Russland wenig überraschend ausgerufen, dass jetzt in all diesen vier vom Krieg betroffenen oblasten,
sogenannte Referenten durchgeführt werden sollen, also in in und.
Auch wenn diese Gebiete ja auch nur teilweise unter russischer Kontrolle sind, also zwar weitgehend, aber ähm ohnehin nur zur Hälfte und ähm.
Saporissia ist ja äh fern, äh ist ja Russland fern jeglicher Komplettkontrolle, aber das interessiert sie ja gar nicht, weil es geht ja auch nicht dadrum,
hier irgendwie der Weltöffentlichkeit irgendwas zu demonstrieren, sondern das ist halt im Wesentlichen eine Botschaft einerseits nach innen.
Zu sagen äh hier gucke mal, hier sind ja alle dafür und war ja im Fernsehen. Also was wollt ihr denn überhaupt? Das ist jetzt Russland.
Und äh andererseits natürlich auch eine Botschaft an die Bevölkerung, indem sie halt einfach äh dazu gezwungen äh wird, jetzt hier an der richtigen Stelle ihr Kreuz zu machen, so nach dem Motto ihr seid jetzt hier irgendwie unser,
Gar nichts.
Aber es ist es ist äh absoluter Fake, diese diese Referenten. Also
Das ist das ja ähm also abgesehen davon wie gesagt das große Teile der Bevölkerung äh gar nicht mehr
da sind, in denen entweder nach Russland oder in die Ukraine geflohen äh gibt's nicht wirklich
Wählerlisten so, weil das ging das Ganze ging halt jetzt auch völlig überhastet und da
sowieso man nur im Prinzip mit ja stimmen darf
eigentlich sind halt ist halt jeder Wähler willkommen und beim letzten Referendum so wurde dokumentiert, wie einige Leute einfach zehn Mal gewählt haben, so also von Wahllokal zu Wahllokal gezogen
sind, nur um das jetzt zu demonstrieren, das sagen ja,
dort keinerlei wirkliche Überprüfung stattfindet, ob jemand wahlberechtigt ist,
Dazu kommt noch, dass die Wahlurnen transparent sind,
und äh die Zettel halt so eingeworfen äh werden, dass man halt sehen kann im Prinzip, wer was wählt und dann noch zu allerletzt,
sind die Optionen auf dem Wahlzettel halt auch nicht jetzt.
Ähm Rückgabe der Kontrolle an die Ukraine oder Anschluss an Russland, sondern die Wahl ist halt zwischen Anschluss an Russland oder,
Status quo, also Autonomie unter russischer Besatzung, wobei natürlich Autonomie äh dann auch noch mal ein Witz ist. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt wählen zwischen ja äh nur sagen, ich,
bleibe, genau, ich bleibe jetzt, äh sagen weiter von den Russen besitzt oder wenn die schon hier sind, dann äh kann ich wenigstens ich sage mal erst mal volle Rechte äh äh haben und kann mich dann drauf berufen.
So
Mhm ja äh dass ich halt die Anspruch auf die ganzen Sozialleistungen und Versorgung und so habe dann als Russe. Das heißt selbst wahrscheinlich selbst wenn die Leute dort fehlen könnten,
So würden viele, die.
Einfach ja nur leben wollen oder irgendwie klar kommen wollen, würden wahrscheinlich sogar bei der Wahl äh zwischen diesen Alternativen erstmal für Anschluss äh äh stimmen, kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Aber am Ende spielt es keine Rolle. Es ist halt einfach nur ähm.
Eine Methode weiter für ein politisches Chaos zu sorgen und in irgendeiner Form eine verzweifelte Botschaft an die russischen Bürger zu senden, dass das hier schon alles seine Ordnung hat, weil guck mal, die sind ja selber dafür. Deswegen sind wir da einmarschiert,
Eigentlich lohnt es sich gar nicht groß darüber noch zu diskutieren.
Man muss es glaube ich trotzdem sagen, weil sonst fälschlicherweise der Eindruck entsteht, da würde irgendwie der Wille
Leute äh dort gemessen äh werden oder so. Das ist einfach eine eine komplett absurde Veranstaltung das Ganze.
Ja, auch eine komplett absurde Veranstaltung scheint, die jetzt jüngst aufgerufene, sogenannte, partielle Mobilisierung zu sein.
Und wir haben ja darüber hier auch schon viel gesprochen.
Und äh ich habe jetzt auch selber mal bei in den Kommentaren nachgeschlagen und nochmal geguckt und festgestellt, dass ich da eine Antwort,
auf einen anderen äh Kommentar geschrieben hatte. Ich glaube nicht, dass Russland noch irgendwelche äh externen Anregungen braucht für irgendwelche Entscheidungen und wenn die Mobilisierung eine politische und technische Option wäre für Putin hätte er sie auch,
schon äh gemacht, aber ist sie ja nicht. Ja, stellt sich raus, jetzt gab es doch eine Mobilisierung. Ähm.
Natürlich sagen Tim lag mal wieder komplett daneben. Glaube ich aber nicht, weil das ist natürlich jetzt etwas, was.
Na ja, vielleicht sollten wir erstmal beschreiben, was da so wirklich bekannt gegeben wurde. Also es wurde halt gesagt, ja.
Wollen jetzt hier ähm mobilisieren, weil unsere Spezialoperation braucht jetzt äh Verstärkung.
In der öffentlichen Ankündigung, war dann so von 300.000 Leuten die Rede, die sie dann äh einziehen wollen würden. Das wäre aber dann ähm,
nach Gebieten gestaffelt, also es gäbe sozusagen ein gewisses Quorum, was dann immer erfüllt werden muss.
Ähm in dem eigentlichen Gesetzestexten, die dort veröffentlicht wurden, ist aber dann von dieser Zahlenbeschränkung so gar nix zu lesen. Man geht kann davon ausgehen, dass das im Prinzip jetzt auch immer so weiter.
Gab ja einige Probleme, vielleicht das noch äh mit der Rekrutierung vorher. Also es gab ja dieses Video, wo dieser Chef, dieser Wagner,
äh Truppe dabei gefilmt wurde äh im Knast Leute zu rekrutieren so nach dem Motto ihr könnt euch ja für die Front melden, dann seid ihr nach sechs Monaten wieder frei, wenn ihr noch.
Ja, super. Ihr habt fünf Minuten äh Zeit euch zu entscheiden. Da sind wohl auch so diverse Leute angekarrt worden, aber ich habe auch schon davon gehört, dass eine ganze Menge dann auch sehr schnell in Bachmut äh,
wurden und äh sozusagen auch schon ihre Zeit jetzt abgesessen haben und schon wieder im Sack nach Hause gefahren.
Bemerkenswert fand ich, dass äh dort der,
Kriegsverlauf oder was die Leute an der Front erwarten äh äh dort von ihm.
Äh äh halt sehr realistisch dargestellt wurde. Also äh
Ja, das war das Ding. Da sagte, ja, nee, ist nicht toll an der Front. Also wahrscheinlich wäre es jetzt nicht überleben. Ähm das fand ich irgendwie.
Und wenn ihr erstmal da seid und ihr dreht oder um und sagt, ihr wollt nicht mit, dann dann erschießen wir euch sofort. Also das sozusagen überhaupt keinen Zweifel daran gelassen wurden, wie die Situation ist.
Jetzt also partielle Mobilmachung, die äh im Prinzip eine versteckte Generalmobilmachung ist, auch wenn sie's halt so nicht nennen.
Und äh interessant fand ich das äh Putin das zwar verkündet hat im Fernsehen, aber davon sprach, es sei ja eine Entscheidung äh der Armee und diese Generalstabs und die sollte man doch mal unterstützen?
So ein bisschen der Versuch sich da auch noch äh rauszuhalten ja also wenn die Arme das entscheidet so äh was was kann ich da.
Ja genau die Armee und Generalstab entscheiden jetzt irgendwie über
Mobilmachung ganz ganz bestimmt. Zumal die in der Hierarchie jetzt der politischen Institution irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, dritter oder vierter Stelle nur rangieren. Also die Armee hat in Russland nicht wirklich viel zu sagen. Vergleich jetzt zu
diversen Geheimdiensten und äh russischer Garde und so weiter. Also ja ähm.
Genau, aber jetzt ist mal ganz interessant zu zu schauen, was da jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich äh
passiert so. Also offiziell wurden ja auch Ausnahmen genannt, so ja, hier wäre in der Militärindustrie arbeitet, den wollen wir gar nicht haben und Studenten auch nicht und natürlich auch keine Leute ohne Militärerfahrung et cetera.
Die Realität ist, dass einfach vor allem,
Also erstmal sehr chaotisch, ohne ordentliche äh Listen offensichtlich Leute einfach,
überall herangekarrt werden. Da sind irgendwie teilweise Leute, die schon seit Jahren tot sind, wurden da irgendwie aufgesucht und sollten verpflichtet werden, aber vor allem
und das hängt halt hinter dieser Quote.
Nach Gebieten ist es halt so, wie es eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit immer war, die Soldaten für diesen Krieg, das Kanonfutter, wird vor allem im fernen Osten akquiriert,
Also während äh es Gebiete gibt ähm.
In Dagistan, in Sachen äh auch auf der Krim äh Macadam, also so auch Orte, wo man erstmal irgendwie die man auch erstmal auf der Landkarte suchen muss, dass man überhaupt weiß, wo wo ist denn das überhaupt?
Dort werden. Also die Leute massiv.
Akquiriert ja also das ging dann in einzelnen Gebieten schon so weit, dass man sagt so ja hier wird irgendwie,
100 Prozent aller jungen Männer akquiriert,
aber dann halt da, wo am meisten Leute wohnen, also in Sankt Petersburg und Moskau, da ist es irgendwie so bestenfalls ein Prozent,
der Leute, die in irgendeiner Form.
Ja, es ist es ist halt, wie du sagst, chaotisch, aber ähm,
nicht nur äh das, sondern äh wie üblich auch in in Russland gibt's halt so dieses,
widersprüchliche Mixed-Messeing, dass sich halt jeder irgendwie raussuchen kann äh äh dort was er will.
Ähm diese es wurden irgendwie zum Beispiel zu der Zahl, ja, wurden in Russland von offizieller Seite,
300tausend kommuniziert, dann wurde aber auch kommuniziert äh dass ja so viel wie nötig. Dann gab es,
außerdem noch Gerüchte, äh dass die offiziell ausgegebene Zahl eine Million äh sein soll,
ne, in Wirklichkeit, was halt die was aber nur Apparats intern quasi äh,
die Zahl sein soll und ähm ja und auch bei der Frage wie gesagt, wer denn eigentlich eingezogen wird äh offiziell.
Erstmal nur Reservisten, ja, plus jetzt äh die normalen Rekruten so normalerweise,
mal 1 Prozent eines Jahrgangs ungefähr eingezogen, 150.000 bis 200.000 Mann pro Jahr ganz normal für die Armee um,
eben im Inland dann ja die Verteidigung zu stärken und aus denen dann wiederum,
rekrutieren sich dann Vertragssoldaten, die dann nochmal unterschreiben können, um entweder länger äh dazubleiben, solange Zeitsoldaten im Grunde genommen und ähm.
Ja ähm wenn jetzt äh Russland allein nur.
Statt 1 Prozent eines Jahrgangs, sehen wir mal 50 Prozent eines Jahrgangs einziehen würde.
Ähm wären das halt äh schon bis zu einer Million.
Junge Leute ja die die eigentlich zur Verfügung stehen
aber tatsächlich äh wiederum gingen eben auch Einberufungsbescheide an Nichtreservisten, an Leute, die nie in der Armee waren.
Überhaupt nicht in die normale Altersgruppe für.
Die nämlich irgendwie von 18 bis 27 geht,
und äh ja, trotzdem eingezogen äh äh werden sollten bis hin, dass tatsächlich,
einfach beliebige junge Leute von der Straße weggeschnappt wurden, so wie zur Zarrenzeit, wo dann die,
äh durch die da verzogen und alle, die sie nicht versteckt haben, wurden dann halt zum Militär einkassiert und das war damals ziemlich krass äh noch zur Zahnzeit, weil
der Militärdienst äh war dann lebenslänglich,
wurde dann hinterher auf 20 Jahre verkürzt äh so, was halt auch nicht so der große Unterschied war, aber äh ja in die Richtung scheint es jetzt äh auch wieder teilweise zu gehen und dem russischen Fernsehen.
Wandern auch äh ein ganz merkwürdige Dinge zu sehen bei der Propaganda, wo irgendwie die Polizei
äh irgendwie in Wohnung eingedrungen ist und dann Leute aus dem Kühlschrank oder äh ausm Sofa rausgezogen hat, die versucht hatten, sich dort äh zu verstecken. Also.
Ganz, ganz kurios, äh was da äh alles gerade passiert und.
Ähm natürlich sehr unklar. Es gab halt Zweifel, dass irgendwie diese dreihunderttausend.
Man überhaupt zusammenkriegt. Ich würde sagen, dass eigentlich.
Jetzt Russland nicht das Problem haben sollte, auch eine Million Leute,
jetzt erstmal ähm ja zu rekrutieren, aber äh die Frage ist natürlich dann oder was.
Derzeit völlig unmöglich oder unwahrscheinlich erscheint ist, dass sie die dann äh auch vernünftig ausgestattet trainiert und eingesetzt kriegen. Aber da kommen wir dann gleich, glaube ich, nochmal zu.
Diese ganze äh Situation hängt natürlich jetzt auch sehr mit diesen Referenten zusammen. Man kann laufen ja offiziell jetzt glaube ich noch bis.
Mittwoch bis zum 28. oder so was und äh na ja niemand erwartet irgendein anderes Ergebnis als ja alle sind dafür und dann wird halt äh Russland eben die Annexion dieser vier Oblaste an äh das russische Staatsgebiet,
erklären, ja, womit ja dann sozusagen die Ukraine im Kampfgebiet aus russischer Perspektive Russland ist. Und damit ändert sich ja automatisch,
äh rechtliche Einordnung, dieses Verbot äh Rekruten im Ausland einzusetzen, entfällt dann, weil es ja Russland.
Dazu kommt auch noch, dass auch die ganzen Verträge, mit denen die dort schon kämpfen, die vielleicht nur auf sechs Monate verpflichtet sind, die wurden dann eben auch nochmal so äh.
Mengen äh,
sozusagen auf auf unbestimmte verlängert. Also bis zum Ende der Spezialoperation sozusagen, sodass also dort,
alle festhängen und äh das hat dann natürlich zu
extremer Panik geführt, weil das ist jetzt natürlich eine Botschaft in die russische Bevölkerung herein, die viele mehr als nur auf dem linken Fuß erwischt hat.
Dazu muss man aber bemerken, dass.
Und das allgemein üblich ist. Das ist das macht sagen jede Armee, das hat auch die US-Armee gemacht, so äh zu bestimmten Zeit,
dass äh wenn ähm ja plötzlich einen Konflikt ausgebrochen äh ist, äh dass dann,
Leute erstmal, die im Operationsgebiet
waren äh oder äh ja, weil man einfach Leute brauchte, das das steht halt in den im Kleingedruckten mit drin oder das weiß halt jeder, okay, wenn's jetzt zum,
Krieg kommt oder äh irgendwie zu einer zu einer Krise, dass dann eben die Leute nicht pünktlich nach Hause äh kommen. Äh,
nicht nach Hause geschickt werden, sondern.
Ja, aber ich habe dann auch Berichte von amerikanischen Generälen und so weiter gesehen. Die meinen so, na ja, das klar, das kann natürlich dann auch passieren, also aber dann
Fliegen sie halt auch mal zu den Eltern und reden mit denen und dann wird da irgendwie Kommunikation geführt und um Verständnis äh
gebeten et cetera, dass ich so einen Einsatz noch verlängert. Ähm das ist natürlich hier fern davon. Aber worauf ich hier eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist,
dass wir's ja jetzt hier mit einer über Jahrzehnte kontinuierlich depolitisierten, russischen Öffentlichkeit zu tun haben,
bisher immer davon ausgegangen ist,
okay, Putin da mit seinem Patriotismus und da machen wir so ein bisschen mit, aber ansonsten lässt du uns in Ruhe, weil wir wollen ja irgendwo auf der Couch sitzen, wir wollen irgendwie
gucken, wir wollen in den Supermarkt gehen und wir wollen irgendwie unserem Mittel äh Klasse Leben führen und wir wollen mit dem ganzen Scheiß nichts zu tun haben und Krieg, das gibt's halt nur im Fernsehen.
Da kämpfen irgendwelche Leute, die sich dafür gemeldet haben und das passt schon und bisher
ja insofern auch immer irgendwie gepasst, dass da dann Leute sterben und Länder überfallen werden. Das wird dann einfach auch mental ausgeblendet und so war's ja jetzt auch bisher
Ukrainekrieg, dass viele Leute einfach in so einem State of die
verblieben sind, so nach dem Motto Ukraine, was geht mich das an? Das sind doch irgendwie die blöden Hochholz, das sind doch hier irgendwie Terroristen und was nicht alles und die NATO.
Das ist alles ganz schlimm. Da muss man auch mal was gegen tun und das macht ja unser Militär.
So
ausgebildeten äh Vertragssoldaten, ne und jetzt durch diese Mobilisierung hat Putin im Prinzip diesen Gesellschaftsvertrag,
aufgekündigt und jetzt kriegen sie's alle mit der Angst. Meine innerhalb von kürzester Zeit waren
alle Flüge ins Ausland in Visa frei äh Länder, wo also die Russen kein Visa beantragen müssen, sofort ausgebucht und wenn's noch einen Platz gab dann so für 30.000 Dollar nach Istanbul und so was.
Und es hat dann auch nicht lange gedauert bis so im Prinzip
an jedem Grenzübergang zu einem dieser Länder, insbesondere nach Finnland und dann äh Georgien auch ganz schnell, Mongolei, et cetera sich äh kilometerlange Staus gebildet haben mit Autos, die halt irgendwie
über die Grenze wollten und halt alles irgendwie junge Männer.
Ja also völlig äh richtig Putin verstößt jetzt gerade gegen diesen grundsätzlichen äh Deal mit dem,
mit der Bevölkerung genau nämlich äh ja das sagen der Deal ist und das das kannte ich auch lang aus,
Tschechien oder damals aus der CSSR nach 1968 war das auch so, war der Deal P okay, wir outsourcen die Politik an euch, äh so ähm,
und äh ihr sorgt aber dafür, dass wir äh halbwegs ordentlich leben,
können so und ähm ja und die Russen sind sicher,
bereit gewisse Abstriche so am ordentlich zu machen, aber wenn's dann ans Leben geht werden auch die Russen so ein bisschen zimperlich, äh so, dass es das ist das Ding und.
Außerdem.
Versucht gerade ja äh äh Putin so ein bisschen einen einen unmöglichen Spagat auf der einen Seite, wenn halt die russische Bevölkerung grundsätzlich weiter politisch passiv halten.
Aber jetzt irgendwie auf der anderen Seite dann militärisch für den Krieg aktivieren und ähm,
Das äh ist natürlich, das funktioniert natürlich so äh selektiv nicht. Das heißt, äh entweder so sie bleiben auf der Couch, aber wir wollen sie dann einmal für von der Couch runterholt oder runterzwingt, dann,
sie selber irgendwie,
plötzlich tun müssen oder involviert sind so, dann äh ja sind sie eben nicht mehr äh so so passiv und wollen dann halt,
äh mitreden.
Und äh dementsprechend wird's halt gerade nicht,
nicht ganz einfach so mit der mit der aktuellen russischen Propaganda.
Das Ganze dann zu erklären und äh die fahren im Moment.
Quasi zwei Wege, äh nämlich auf der einen Seite Backen weg vom Thema Ukraine.
So ist es jetzt halt kein Konflikt mehr mit der Ukraine oder die ganze Thema Nazibekämpfung und so, sondern es wird jetzt auf Konflikt mit der NATO und den Amerikanern, ja?
Äh
30 Prozent der ukrainischen Truppen werden ja von der.
So und auf der anderen Seite
versucht man halt äh zu sagen, aber es wird euch trotzdem nur am Rande betreffen. Wir haben zwar irgendwie die halbe Welt gegen uns oder 3 Viertel der Welt, je nachdem, wie man das misst
äh so
Es wird euch trotzdem nur am Rande betreffen. Wir ziehen halt nur ein paar Reservisten und ein paar junge Wehrpflichtige ein und ihr merkt eigentlich gar nichts davon, ja? Also in diese beiden
Richtungen äh wird halt kommuniziert.
Und das ist aber auch eine bewährte Propagandamethode, weil jeder kann sich dann so ein bisschen das raussuchen, äh was er gerne hören will und ganz viele Leute merkt man ja auch ähm
bei jeder Online-Debatte haben halt keine Probleme, äh zwei völlig widersprüchliche Dinge für sich im Kopf zu haben und diesen Widerspruch.
Äh einfach wegzu ignorieren, ja und,
Das äh also eine typische Nazinummer oder Populismus äh Nummer oder was jetzt halt weiß ich nicht auch die Wagenknecht jetzt in ihrer Rede äh hat das irgendwie dann genauso äh.
Die Nummer gefahren, aber äh ja Problem.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall vielleicht noch diese die politische Gesamtsituation,
ändert sich dadurch. Also die ganze innenpolitische Gesamtsituation sowohl für die normalen Bürger als auch eben für die Leute, die schon im Kriegseinsatz äh sind, ja. Es ist zwar nach wie vor kein Krieg
erklärt worden so ne
ähm aber durch diese Annektion, die jetzt äh kommen wird, äh arbeiten sozusagen alle in Russland und damit wissen halt auch alle,
dass sie auf einmal in diesem Krieg eingesetzt werden können, ne? Das heißt, auch alle, die jetzt gerade
neu eingezogen wurden, kommen im Prinzip ja auch noch mit dazu und.
Man sieht ja an dieser Reaktion also erstens, dass.
Alle sofort ab in die Flugzeuge, ab an die Grenze. So, dann ging's auch relativ schnell, dass an den Flughäfen auch schon so eine Ausreisesperre für 18 bis 65-jährige Männer
verfügt wurde an den Grenzen also an den Straßengrenzen wird jetzt auch gemunkelt dass so nach Ablauf der.
Der Referenten, also ein, zwei Tagen dann äh dort auch
gemacht werden soll, gibt es auch schon Bilder von Militär, was jetzt an die Grenzen äh fährt. Da in äh verschiedenen äh Bereichen, also an diesen Warteschlangen entlang, vor allem kommen dann auf einmal so
Armeefahrzeuge und werden jetzt wahrscheinlich demnächst die Grenzen,
dort absichern. Das heißt, sie haben auch schon Schiss, dass ihnen jetzt irgendwie alle davonlaufen und das hat natürlich dann nochmal einen anderen ähm,
Effekt, dass natürlich die jetzt dann versuchen sich innerhalb von Russland zu verstecken. Das,
auch schon viele Berichte, dass also viele einfach irgendwie weg sind und das Problem ist, im Zweifelsfall kommen sie dich holen. Also entweder holen sie dich zu Hause ab,
sie holen dich eine Arbeitsstätte ab und weil sie das natürlich auch nicht wollen, gehen die Leute auch nicht mehr arbeiten.
Das betrifft halt jetzt nicht nur die theoretisch 3hundert000 Leute, sondern es ist halt alle, die jetzt Schiss haben und das geht dann halt mal schnell so.
Ins Zehnfache davon,
heißt du hast jetzt irgendwie drei Millionen, 4 Millionen Leute, die alle Schiss haben, sie könnten morgen eingezogen werden, deswegen nicht mehr arbeiten gehen, sich irgendwo äh
gleich über die Grenze abhauen, äh sonst wie sich in irgendeiner Form der Öffentlichkeit entziehen und damit natürlich auch der Wirtschaft entziehen.
Es wird auch vermutet, dass jetzt nicht nur Russland quasi die Außengrenzen dicht
machen könnte, sondern vielmehr sogar noch die inneren Grenzen, also zwischen den einzelnen Subjekten äh der der Föderation, so dass also das Reisen innerhalb von Russland dann auch für bestimmte Teile
der Bevölkerung, nämlich Männer im Wehrpflichtigen Alter erschwert äh werden wird und nur mit,
Wenn man dann speziellen äh Ausweisen äh möglich ist äh wo dann draufsteht, dass du.
Hm ja Reisen darfst und eben nicht äh von der Wehrpflicht.
Bist oder aus anderen Gründen freigestellt und.
Was natürlich das ganze Thema dann jetzt in in einem korrupten Land wie Russland natürlich,
nach sich zieht, äh sagen Missbrauch, dass halt willkürlich dann Leute eben auch,
zur Bestrafung oder die man nicht leiden kann oder Angehörige von Minderheiten oder so einfach so ad hoc eingezogen werden oder äh umgekehrt
dann natürlich Leute in dieser Machtposition äh sich dann auch einfach bereichern werden. Das heißt, dass du dann auch gegen Geld quasi äh dann so eine Freistellung dir kaufen kannst. So,
und da werden ganz mit Sicherheit äh viele Leute in der Armee auch in den Reibach machen. Gerade mit.
Beziehungsweise wurde er auch schon schön gezeigt, äh wie sich die Elite dann eben wiederum dieser Einberufung entzieht. Hast du das mitbekommen mit dieser Fernsehsendung, wo sie den Sohn äh des äh Armeesprechers angerufen haben?
So ein so ein Fernsehsender, der äh glaube ich hier von dem ähm wie heißt hier noch gleich der äh russische, also.
Vielleicht das richtige Wort, den sie den den sie hier irgendwie Nawalny genauso aus aus dessen Netzwerk,
Kommt das? Äh gibt's halt so eine Fernsehsendung und da haben dann die Moderatoren äh live den den Sohn von dem Armeesprecher angerufen, der halt.
In der Armee ausgebildet ist, weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, in welchem Segment, aber der hat sozusagen erfüllt alle Anforderungen, Alter, et cetera und da haben sie sich ausgegeben, als das Einberufungsamt.
Wo er denn geblieben wäre und er hätte ihm einen Brief geschickt und er soll hier morgen mal um zehn hier irgendwie
sein und zack, zack, weißt du, so richtig knallhart, irgendwie so eine Ansage gemacht und du merkst so richtig, wie der so völlig aus den Wolken gefallen ist und er so äh wärst du? Nein, irgendwie Sie sind ja hier irgendwie beim falschen und so weiter und Sie so, nein, nein, wir wissen ja
sie sind und hier und der Name und morgen und sind ja hier jetzt ist irgendwie Mobilisierung. Und dann hat er dann halt irgendwann das Gespräch beendet mit so, na ja nee,
ich werde das auf einem anderen Wege lösen, so nach dem Motto äh.
Wissen Sie nicht, wer ich bin und äh so weiter. Wodurch natürlich dann auch schnell klar wurde, äh dass die Elite sich dem eben auch noch entzieht, wären halt die ganzen Versprechen aus dem Gesetz und aus der öffentlichen Ankündigung
so nicht eingehalten werden. Du hast ja schon gesagt, Leute, die zu alt sind, Leute, die krank sind, Leute
irgendwie ein Bein fehlt, ja? Auch Leute, die in Waffenproduktionsstätten arbeiten, wurden dann auf einmal eingezogen. Ne, damit kriegen natürlich die Firmen, müssen natürlich jetzt
auch äh richtig mit der Angst, weil dieser Entzug von im Prinzip ja der wichtigsten.
Demographischen Gruppe für den für den Arbeitsmarkt.
Also junge Männer, die irgendwie in der Wirtschaft arbeiten, äh die dann auf einmal nicht mehr zum,
Arbeit erscheinen, das wird also der ohnehin schon stark gebeutelten.
Eine erheblichen Schlag und das auch sehr schnell
versetzen, dass das Ganze wird also den Druck, der jetzt hier auf diesem Gesellschaftskessel ist, noch weiter äh,
erhöhen, ne und dann kommen auch noch so Aspekte wie dazu, wenn jetzt irgendwie alles Russland ist, jahrpflichtige können dort eingesetzt werden, aber dadurch entziehen sie sozusagen auch noch den Vertragssoldaten ihre Zusatzzahlungen,
die sie nur bekommen, wenn sie im Ausland eingesetzt werden.
Ja? Äh also niemand wird da besonders äh froh drüber sein. Außerdem gibt es mittlerweile viele Proteste in diesen ganzen benachteiligten Gebieten halt im Osten und im Süden, wo einfach,
man sagen kann, da ist diese Mobilisierung im Prinzip auch nochmal so eine indirekte, ethnische Säuberung, ja, weil wenn da einfach noch mehr Leute abgezogen äh werden, verlieren diese Gebiete also in zunehmendem Maße ihre äh
ihre ethnischen äh Minderheiten, die also ursprünglich da mal einfach primär da waren, ne und man kennt das aus vielen Gebieten, dass halt immer mehr mit,
weißen Russen äh sozusagen ähm.
Dort äh die Gebiete übernommen werden und das schafft jetzt einfach mit einem Schlag so viel Angst und so viel Ungerechtigkeit.
Ähm dass ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen kann
dass das folgenlos bleiben wird. Ich meine, es gab viele Proteste in den Städten, da würden dann teilweise die Protestler nicht nur festgenommen, sondern auch gleich mit ihren Einberufungsbescheiden äh versehen, so nach dem Motto, ah, du demonstrierst ja gegen den Krieg, super, dann fahren wir dich da gleich mal hin,
dass alle jetzt so total Angst haben, das siehst du dann übrigens auch an Googletrends. Kaum war das verkündet, war dann so die meiste Suche irgendwie leave rusher.
Also dann auf russisch natürlich, ne? Äh oder how to break my arm so. Also das ist meine.
Ist schon lustig, wenn's wenn's nicht so furchtbar wäre, aber äh das zeigt meiner Meinung nach, dass einfach Putin hier äh mit seinem Latein am Ende war. Sie sehen, dass sie diesen Krieg gerade verlieren.
Massiv, dass dass sie einfach jetzt wirklich in die Defensive sind und geben im Prinzip.
Äh diesen ultranationalisten jetzt quasi was sie haben wollten, weil die die ganze Zeit nach Mobilisierung geschrien haben, obwohl sie eigentlich, und das war ja.
Eingangs diesem Segment, habe ich das ja gesagt, auch immer unsere Einschätzung, dass eigentlich so eine Mobilisierung aus russischer Perspektive
extrem kontraproduktiv ist, weil sie das technisch nicht durchziehen können, weil sie das organisatorisch nicht hinkriegen, weil diese Leute diesen diese Kampfverbände nicht wirklich in
eigentlich im Sinne verstärken, sondern am Ende ihnen vielleicht sogar noch mehr Probleme machen, weil die müssen die ausrüsten, die müssen die ernähren. Äh die machen Ärger. Die sind demoralisiert schon, wenn sie da ankommen. Die sind teilweise gegen den Krieg. Die werden sich wahrscheinlich auch einfach äh einfach sofort mit einer weißen Fahne irgendwie an die Front begeben und gleich wieder weglaufen.
Ja, ich meine, ganz so einfach ist das nicht. Es ist Militär hat Jahrtausende Erfahrung, wie man unwillige
Leute trotzdem äh zu äh unglaublichen äh Dingen äh veranlasst, also andere äh zu,
oder sich töten zu lassen. Insofern ganz so einfach.
Ist es nicht, aber trotzdem äh ja äh haben gedacht, okay äh wenn man,
Putin dann aber eine Gelegenheit oder einen Anlass gibt,
sich ins Knie zu schießen, dann äh ja wird man wahrscheinlich nicht enttäuscht und in dem Fall habe ich das Gefühl, äh hat er sich aber in beide Knie und noch in die Hoden geschossen, ja.
So den den Eindruck äh habe ich, aber er hat natürlich auch einen einen super,
Dilemma äh jetzt und mhm am Ende war's wahrscheinlich die erfolgreiche Gegenoffensive, die,
ihn jetzt komplett aus dem Konzept gebracht hat beziehungsweise äh die Planung über den Haufen äh geworfen hat, weil auf der einen Seite kommt die Mobilmachung militärisch zu spät.
Um jetzt irgendwie,
in den nächsten Wochen oder Monaten irgendwas zu bewirken, hätte das viel früher hätte das vor Monaten passieren müssen, so eigentlich fast zu Beginn äh der.
Offensive wie die Ukraine, die es gemacht hat. Politisch aber äh kommt sie jetzt verfrüht und meine Vermutung.
Ist, dass das so nicht geplant war, dass der Plan eigentlich anders aussah. Ähm,
was logisch gewesen wäre, als der Plan so aussah, okay, wir machen jetzt Referendum äh und annektieren die Gebiete.
So. Anschließend.
Lassen wir sagen dann die Ukraine angreifen und reden dann was von Invasion, von russischen Territorium.
Und mobilisieren dann dadurch die Bevölkerung erstmal politisch. Dass sie dann danach schreien.
So äh ja äh so Russland ist jetzt wird jetzt angegriffen und jetzt müssen wir aber und dann wäre quasi äh.
Sagen die Bereitschaft auch für eine militärische Mobilisierung da, die dann von weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung getragen wird. Aber irgendwie haben sie jetzt den Schritt vier zuerst gebracht so ähm,
dann äh äh kommt jetzt eins und zwei und dann hofft man irgendwie auf,
politische Mobilisierung, aber meine.
Auch starke Vermutung ist, dass dadurch, dass man den Schritt vier jetzt zuerst gemacht hat, man riesige Probleme haben wird.
Äh zu sagen äh dann oh jetzt die bösen Ukrainer und so, die.
Greifen uns jetzt an, sondern ich meine so dumm sind die Russen dann dann dann jetzt auch nicht,
und hm ja also in insofern äh glaube ich
hat sich da Putin erstmal wirklich wieder sich und den den Russen äh ein ziemlich dickes Ei gelegt jetzt mit dieser Teilmobilisierung.
So, aber die Erwartung ist jetzt okay, Virenlisch werden die Russen denn und äh.
Der Eindruck, wenn man von Russland-Kennern ist.
Dass die Russen wohl diese Mobilisierung so lange tolerieren werden.
Wie sie dann doch irgendwie Erfolge verspricht oder,
zeigt. So. Das heißt, quasi Putin wird jetzt erstmal nicht sofort gestürzt, weil es wird nicht sofort die Revolution ausbrechen, aber,
Wenn das jetzt eben zu weiteren Rückschlägen kommt und spätestens.
Im Frühjahr diese Mobilisierung nicht klare Erfolge äh bringen wird, dann ist die allgemeine Einschätzung dann äh sagen äh werden.
Russen ihm die weitere Gefolgschaft verweigern äh definitiv und dann.
Ist da wahrscheinlich weg vom Fenster, so das heißt er ist jetzt quasi ja schön heißt all in,
und entweder das klappt jetzt mit der Mobilisierung und wenn nicht, dann dann war's das. Also jetzt irgendwie das Ding wieder einschlafen zu lassen oder dann,
sagen Normalität einkehren zu lassen und die Russen wieder auf die Couch zurückzuschicken. Das wird nicht mehr möglich sein.
Das ist so die Einschätzung.
So, die Situation jetzt um die Mobilmachung und vor allem um die.
Ja
Versuchte Ausreise so vieler Russen wirft natürlich jetzt äh international auch noch mal ein anderes Problem auf. Wir hatten ja auch schon vorher in der EU diese Debatte.
Ähm ob man denn jetzt die.
Einreisebedingungen für die Russen ändern soll, ob man sozusagen generell keine Visa mehr vergeben soll, dann hatten wir letzte Mal auch schon erwähnt, dass,
zumindest dieser visa Prozess als solcher ähm,
schon mal eingeschränkt wurde oder zumindest diese existierenden Verbesserungen für Russen äh zurückgenommen wurden.
Und das bricht natürlich jetzt nochmal komplett neu auf, weil grade in Finnland so die Situation ist, ja, was machen wir jetzt mit denen, äh die balischen Staaten haben irgendwie sofort gesagt, so ich brauche ja überhaupt gar nicht erst anzuklopfen, hier kommt ja irgendwie gar nicht rein.
Und Deutschland hatte ja bisher immer so diese Position mit Jannik, wir machen da irgendwie keine Einschränkungen und äh und so weiter und das ist natürlich jetzt wirklich eine schwierige Situation politisch, ne,
weil in gewisser Hinsicht,
spricht ja äh sicherlich für für beide Verhaltensweisen irgendwie etwas, ne. Also so aus der Position der Balken heraus oder der Leute, die oder der Länder, die eben,
für ein Einreiseverbot sind so.
Kann man sagen gut, wenn man da halt jetzt zumacht, dann erhöht das eben den sozialen Druck in Russland so und hilft dann vielleicht.
Theoretisch auch irgendwelchen revolutionären Tendenzen, wobei ich glaube, das ist dann doch sehr optimistisch äh gedacht. Ähm.
Die Eingezogenen, ja, die potenziell gegen den Krieg sind, die machen ja dann auch mehr Ärger, wenn sie an der Front sind so und äh.
Vielleicht auch gleich äh ergeben und dann ist natürlich auch so generell dieses Sicherheitsproblem ne, wenn du jetzt auf einmal wieder viele Leute über die
Grenze äh drücken und man überprüft das nicht groß und lässt sich einfach mal rein, sagt dem Motto ihr seid ja alle diese Türer und dann haben wir euch auch lieb
da sich natürlich dann auch wiederum Spione oder andere Agenten drunter mischen können, die dann halt,
potenziell die Länder infiltriert. Ich denke mal, also das ist jetzt so, ich sage nur, das sind so die die Argumentationen und die Gedanken, die sicherlich
solchen Entscheidungen, bei solchen politischen Tendenzen eine Rolle spielen.
Der anderen Seite könnte man auch sagen na ja äh wenn man die Leute jetzt sozusagen reinlässt und fliehen lässt so, dann äh.
Dann verhindern wir sozusagen, dass auch neue Leute rekrutiert werden können, ne? Wobei da ist ja das Potenzial an Leuten nach wie vor groß genug oder man könnte auch allgemein sagen, äh es sind ja dann irgendwie auch Flüchtlinge und die sollte man irgendwie auch.
Aufnehmen.
Ja das Interessante ist, äh dass aber äh aus russischer Sicht sozusagen genau dasselbe gilt.
Und äh jetzt irgendwie Blatt wächst, ne, den ich auch,
eine höhere äh Exil äh russischer Intellektueller, der.
Wie ich finde sehr gut die Situation in Russland analysiert. Ähm der.
Meinte, sagen wir den wie den Putin äh das Ganze wohl,
sieht und äh seine Einschätzung ist, na ja äh man findet das zu 60 Prozent,
ungefähr schlecht und zu 40 Prozent gut
So ja also so ungefähr sieht es aus russischer Seite äh äh auf russischer Seite aus, das heißt auch da ist man einerseits eben froh.
Potentielle Stören, Friede loszuwerden und da gab's ja auch schon so Ansagen ja irgendwie wer da nicht zu Russland steht, der ist halt ein Feind und soll halt lieber gleich ganz wegbleiben.
Und äh ja so sieht's halt aus auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich auch einen Brain Brain, der da passiert und äh insofern.
Ist diese äh Zwiespalt, sage ich mal, auf beiden Seiten grade vorhanden.
Schwierig da auch irgendwie eine Position äh zu finden, ne? Also hatten wir ja vorhin schon erwähnt, also die Auswirkung auf die Wirtschaft, die werden auf jeden Fall sichtbar werden.
Aber wie man sich jetzt hier stellt äh ist so eine Sache. Ich habe die Bewertung äh gelesen von dir, aber meint, na ja, man sollte auf jeden Fall irgendwie,
äh von dem machen, was Putin macht, also wenn er sie alle rauslässt so, dann äh,
dann sollte man sie vielleicht nicht reinlassen, aber wenn wenn er die Grenzen zumacht, dann vielleicht schon. Insofern äh ändert sich das ja jetzt gerade.
Ähm weil ja das wahrscheinlich jetzt auch die Bewertung äh sich äh inner russisch so weit wohl schon verändert zu haben,
scheint, dass das eher ein Problem ist und dass jetzt hier die Repression auch ansetzt, was ja schon erwähnt so, ne, unter Umständen sogar auch,
zwischen den einzelnen äh Regionen noch äh Grenzen zu setzen. So oder so äh wird die Situation für Russland einfach schwieriger und ich,
den Eindruck, dass diese ganze Mobilmachung unterm Strich wenig bringen wird, was.
Militärischen Erfolg betrifft, den man sich davon verspricht.
Aus den bereits genannten Gründen dauert lange und wenn's nicht lange dauert, sind die alle schlecht trainiert und noch weniger motiviert.
Ähm und ähm andererseits.
Führt es einfach zu diesem fortgesetzten
teilweise überhaupt erst einsetzenden Konflikt mit einer Bevölkerung oder zumindest einem Bevölkerungsteil, der in gewisser Hinsicht auch die Mehrheit ausmacht
bisher immer gesagt haben, naja wir lassen euch machen, aber lasst uns in Ruhe. Und jetzt werden sie nicht mehr in Ruhe gelassen oder haben zumindest Angst davor, nicht in Ruhe gelassen zu werden und das äh ja das
klingt nicht klingt nicht gut.
Ja. Ja, aber wie schon gesagt, Putin ist jetzt äh all in äh äh gegangen, so hat quasi jetzt nochmal.
Ja äh mehr in den Pott äh reingeworfen und äh ja.
Muss jetzt es muss jetzt Ergebnisse äh bringen, sonst war's das für Putin, wenn das nicht in den nächsten Monaten oder spätestens bis zum Frühjahr ähm.
Die Wände bringt und warum? Das sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, dass das passiert äh da äh
denke ich äh da da habe ich auch noch ein paar äh ja interessante Dinge rausgefunden, warum ganz unabhängig von tagespolitischen Ereignissen oder so, warum das nicht funktionieren kann, zu sagen aus mathematischen Gründen nicht.
Nicht ausführen.
Später doch. Wegen ja sozusagen beim Qualität versus Quantitätsthema.
Ah ja.
Was es auch noch gab, was man sicherlich noch erwähnen sollte, ist ein vielbeachteter Gefangenenaustausch zwischen der Ukraine und Russland.
Vermittelt durch äh Erdogan in der Türkei.
Glaube ich unterm Strich auch eher als Erfolg für die Ukraine gewertet werden kann. Hm konkret sind dort zweihundertfünfzehn.
Ukrainische Bürger ähm von Russland an die Ukraine zurücküberstellt worden.
Da drunter befanden sich 100 Kämpfer, die in Asowstal,
in der da lange lange Zeit haben und äh ja dadurch auch schon zu den Superhelden der Ukraine äh geworden sind, also das.
Bis hin in diesen ukrainische Band da gewonnen hat, die noch in ihrer.
Abschieds äh Aufführung irgendwie gesagt hat hier Asostal unterstützt sie.
Et cetera, die müssen jetzt hier alle freikommen. Und jetzt sind sie halt frei gekommen, also,
aber viele dadrunter auch wohl fünf der Kommandeure.
Allerdings nicht in die Ukraine überstellt wurden, sondern die bis zum Ende des Konflikts so die Absprache in der Türkei verbleiben sollen und wohl auch zehn äh amerikanische, britische, andere äh nicht ukrainische Kämpfer, die dabei waren.
Was kriegt Russland dafür? Es sind äh ja nur 55russische Soldaten überstellt worden.
Und äh ein Herr namens Medwitchuk. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir den mal erwähnt haben. Ich meine ja.
Der ja so einer so ein ukrainischer äh ein reicher ukrainischer Unternehmer ist, der schon immer irgendwie Russland unterstützt hat und so ein enger Freund von Putin war und äh der so in den ersten zwei Monaten irgendwann,
versucht hat zu fliehen und dann aber aufgespürt wurde und von den Ukrainern,
festgenommen wurde und ja das haben sie jetzt eben getauscht und die Ankunft dieser Azowstalkämpfer ist natürlich dann viel bejubelt worden in der Ukraine.
Und die russischen Nationalisten waren nicht begeistert, dass quasi sozusagen Russland auf der einen Seite sagen mit
wird Schuk so einen Großkopf hatten, äh sagen dafür, dann weiß ich nicht 2hundert äh ja Ukrainer
freigelassen äh wurden, aber man natürlich sagen, Russen sind ja mehr wert als Ukrainer, insofern äh ja aus Putins Sicht insofern.
Äh ja wer weiß, aber das ist natürlich auch wieder so ein äh äh so ein Ding gewesen, ja. Also wieder so eine typisch äh russische,
Nummer.
Beleuchtet aber diesen Konflikt, den wir schon angesprochen haben, auch noch mal stark und das muss man ja an der Stelle, glaube ich, auch nochmal betonen.
Dieses Kräftespiel in der russischen Gesellschaft und die Frage äh wem ist Putin eigentlich in irgendetwas in irgend einer Hinsicht etwas schuldig.
Kann man schon ganz gut dran festmachen, dass er im Prinzip von zwei Seiten äh Probleme hat,
Auf der einen Seite sind das halt die Regime.
Kritiker, die Regime, Gegner, die aufgeklärten, die ja einfach jetzt über Jahrzehnte konsequent äh unterdrückt hat,
in gewisser Hinsicht auch total egal sind. Aber auf der anderen Seite eben auch diese ultranationalistischen Kräfte.
Auch so in den Medien sehr präsent sind und die eben im das im Prinzip alles gar nicht äh genug Eskalation sein kann, ne und diejenigen wäre im Prinzip jetzt auch
dahin gebracht haben zu sagen, okay, das machen wir halt, diese blöde Mobilisierung.
Und wenn die halt nicht begeistert sind von solchen Sachen, dann ist das irgendwie äh für ihn auch nicht hilfreich.
Ja, also mein Eindruck wäre eher, dass sozusagen die Opposition in dem Sinne.
Eher an dritter Stelle oder fast unter ferner Liefen im Moment äh sich sich befinden und,
im Moment nicht wirklich gefährlich werden können, sondern dass es mehr sagen auf der einen Seite, wie du richtig sagtest, so die Nationalisten sind, die am liebsten gleich einen Atomkrieg anzetteln äh würden.
Auf der anderen Seite, glaube ich, eher so die Technokraten im russischen Staatsapparat, so die,
halt äh die Budgets sehen und sehen, was da wirklich passiert und voran äh geht und
wie ja unschön die die Folgen sind, auch für sie persönlich und die da, glaube ich, eher äh ja, also im sozusagen im Apparat ähm,
eher diejenigen sind, die da von Putin nicht begeistert sind und ihm vielleicht gefährlich werden können oder gefährlich Herr werden könnten.
Dann haben wir natürlich viel äh Diskussionen auch wieder gesehen um das leidige Thema der Waffenliederlieferung.
Einerseits halt der Waffenlieferung Deutschlands. Da gab's wieder ein bisschen Bewegung. Es sind wieder äh vier von diesen Panzerhaubitzen 20000 geliefert worden und 50 Dingos, das sind so äh.
Geländewagen.
Ja also gepanzerte äh Geländewagen et cetera,
gut Deutschland hat ja auch schon mal diese Liste veröffentlicht, was ja alles schon geschickt haben und ohne Zweifel ist das alles auch irgendwie hilfreich, aber wir hatten ja schon angesprochen, äh diese Panzerlieferung, das das äh bleibt einfach der Knackpunkt und es ist einfach.
Aus meiner Perspektive nicht mehr nachzuvollziehen, warum die deutsche Regierung hier so eine Blockadehaltung einnimmt.
Erschließt sich logisch nicht und es erschließt sich meiner Meinung nach auch politisch nicht und äh die Wahrnehmung Deutschlands, ich weiß gar nicht, ob sich das hier alle so,
klarmachen, also in den deutschen Medien wird das auf jeden Fall meiner Meinung nach noch nicht so reflektiert ist,
wie groß der Gesichtsverlust ist, den den Deutschland in diesem ganzen Konflikt mittlerweile erlitten hat und weiter erleidet.
Diese merkwürdige Zurückhaltung.
Was halt natürlich auch äh sagen ernste Folgen haben wird für die Situation, wenn die ganze Sache irgendwann mal zu Ende ist. Ähm.
Und insbesondere wenn dann ja die.
So wird schon, wenn wenn äh Russland irgendwie den Kürzeren äh ziehen sollte, äh wird Deutschland,
quasi ja äh insbesondere von den von den osteuropäischen Ländern, die werden sich halt einfach nix mehr sagen lassen, so wie Polen oder gut. Sowieso nicht, aber das wird halt dann äh ja
bis hin zu den zu den Amerikanern, äh die einfach auch,
Ja äh nicht begeistert sein werden und von der Ukraine, dann ganz zu schweigen, ja und das das Bedauerliche ist ja, dass wir alle Opfer bringen, so finanzieller,
Art äh auf jeden Fall und äh ich fühle mich da so ein bisschen in der Situation wie auch die die Russen. Äh ja, also wenn wir schon.
Jetzt äh hier die ganze äh äh die ganze Kacke. Ähm ertragen äh müssen, so dann würde ich eigentlich auch gerne sehen, dass das,
Effekt zeigt und zwar hm einerseits tatsächlich Effekt in der Ukraine zeigt, aber auch äh ja, dass das international entsprechend,
gewürdigt wird auch das das Engagement und da,
Das kann ich nicht wirklich nachvollziehen, warum hm oder ich kann's nachvollziehen oder ich habe meine Vermutung, warum jetzt gerade die SPD.
Dort äh so äh blockiert. Ich ich denke, das hat was auch mit äh.
Geschichte mit irgendwie Willy Brandt und seinem,
Kniefall äh zu tun unter anderem so und das ist natürlich alles jetzt tot quasi, ja so diese ganze,
hm ja Historie Deutschland äh Russland und so mit dem,
äh mit dem Kniefall und äh ja mit wie Freundschaft das.
Ja dass das
war einmal, aber die SPD hängt da irgendwie immer noch dran fest. Ich meine, so wie die SPD auch damals zum Beispiel in Berlin an am Jeroseky-Regime festgehalten hat, ja und ähm gegen Solidarnosch
äh lange Zeit. So lässt es halt, ja SPD irgendwie und.
Insofern äh plus.
Ähm es könnte sein, dass er schlicht einfach vor seiner Basis äh auch auch irgendwie Angst hat, obwohl mich das sehr wundern würde. Das ist eher, das sind eher die Grünen, die.
Eher äh in ihrer Position oder die Grüne, die Grünen Minister, die da eher ein bisschen vor ihrer Basis äh kuschen.
Müssen und und dementsprechend halt das ganze Thema Menschenrechte und so äh da nicht so.
Kompromisse machen können, also ist halt die grüne Basis dann so ein bisschen äh ja gespalten natürlich, aber.
Ja was die SPD angeht.
Nicht mehr so sicher. Ich meine, von welcher Basis redest du da? Das du redest wahrscheinlich von dieser klassischen grünen Basis.
Parteibasis.
Sinne, ja die Partei aber nicht unbedingt die Parteibasis heute, sondern eher die Parteibasis von, die mal die Grünen gegründet hat, also so dieser klare äh plakative Pazifismus
nicht wahr so das war ja lange Zeit etwas was die Partei zerrissen hat aber das sehe ich halt derzeit bei den Grünen so überhaupt nicht mehr.
Nee, nee, es ist gar nicht.
Ja auch die Position äh von von Habeck und Baerbocks sind ja auch relativ klar. Also ich denke, wenn's nach dem gehen würde, dann würde sich die ganze Bundesregierung ganz anders ausrichten. Das,
Herrn Scholz.
Was ich meine ist, äh zu sagen, es gibt da quasi bei den bei den Grünen, sage ich mal,
zwei Arten von äh Grundsätzen, so die die Partei sehr sehr hoch hält oder die Basis sehr hoch hält und,
das ganze Thema natürlich Menschenrechte und Kompromisse mit Diktatoren und Gewalttätern äh und so und ja,
ähm Völkermördern äh einzugehen, dass es sozusagen der der Punkt eher, dass sozusagen die die grüne Basis, äh dass den sehr übel nehmen würde, äh wenn sie äh dort,
einen soften Kurs fahren würden gegenüber äh diesen Menschenrechtsverletzern. Das ist glaube ich so eher.
Die äh ja der der der Druck, der aus der Partei kommt.
In der ganzen Debatte stellt sich ja eigentlich immer so die Frage welches nie wieder hätte man denn jetzt gerne so ja? Äh so nie wieder Krieg ist so ein bisschen,
schön gesagt so, aber die Frage ist ja, was sind die Bedingungen und äh man kann's halt auch mit nie wieder ausschwitz und oder nie wieder Genozid ähm beschreiben und.
Zumindest aus meiner Perspektive die Haltung eigentlich relativ klar wohin ich gehe. Ich meine dieser Krieg ist ja jetzt nicht gewählt.
Krieg ist ja äh von außen aufgedrängt worden und der verschwindet jetzt auch nicht dadurch, dass man den sich wegwünscht, sondern es gibt einfach nur mal ganz klar derzeit keine andere.
Option. Es gibt keine Friedensverhandlungen, die man da jetzt führen kann
keine der beiden Seiten ist in der Lage oder auch nur bereit welche äh zu führen und äh das wird sicherlich irgendwann mal anstehen, aber ist derzeit einfach überhaupt gar keine Option, sondern es geht's halt einfach nur um das nackte Überleben großer
Teile der ukrainischen Bevölkerung und es ist offensichtlich, dass man jetzt hier nur äh Erfolge erzielen kann, indem man dagegen hält,
Natürlich haben wir die Möglichkeit hier noch sehr viel mehr zu helfen.
Es wird halt nicht getan und ich habe auch verschiedene Leute gefragt so, ob sich das irgendjemand erklären kann, warum Deutschland jetzt eigentlich gegen die Lieferung von Kampfpanzern ist.
Insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund, dass Sie ja auch andere schwere Waffen, was ja lange Zeit so ein bisschen das.
Der politische Term war, der so ein bisschen durch die Räume geworfen wurde. Ja, schwere Waffen und so weiter, voll schwierig. Auch wenn das ja an sich schon kaum zu definieren ist. Äh ja, aber die Panzerhaubitze 2000 ist ja jetzt kein Leichtgewicht.
Und auch die Gepard Flugabwehr Panzer sind jetzt nicht gerade leicht leichte.
Kampftechnik.
Also logisch ist das Ganze irgendwie nicht so, dass das äh.
Denke ich, kann man festhalten und mein Eindruck war auch hieß ja dann immer ähm.
So von wegen keine deutschen Alleingänge, aber mein Eindruck war eher äh so, was jetzt die amerikanische Position angeht war, dass die so bisschen auf Deutschland gucken und sagen, na.
Führt doch mal jetzt ein bisschen. Kinder lernt doch mal jetzt ein bisschen selber mal,
eigene Schritte äh zu machen. Wartet doch nicht immer auf uns äh ja so macht doch mal selber, ihr seid irgendwie die größte Volkswirtschaft äh in in Europa, so ähm ja.
Werdet doch selber bitte mal aktiv. Warum müssen wir euch immer zum Jagen tragen? Ja, das ist so war mein Eindruck ähm eher.
Dass äh.
Während umgekehrt dann Deutschland sich lieber äh aber hinter anderen versteckt und sagt ja wir wollen aber nicht uns jetzt nicht vorwagen und Russen sind sonst böse auf uns äh und so und ja.
Ich meine, die die Argumentationslinie derzeit ist ja eher so ein bisschen der Talking Point ist so, ja, wir wollen ja keine Alleingänge machen.
Aber eigentlich alle Länder sagen so, oh nö, das ist eigentlich schon so eurer,
kann schon jedes Land für sich selber entscheiden. So, das sagen alles, vor allem die Amerikaner. Ich glaube, es gibt relativ wenig Verständnis für diese Widerstände und,
kann man natürlich sagen, ja okay, die Amerikaner liefern aber auch keine äh Kampfpanzer. Was da ist, die konkrete,
politische Argumentation dahinter ist weiß ich nicht aber ich finde sie ist auch entkoppelt
von dem. Ja? Es ist ja vollkommen unerheblich davon, was jetzt die Amerikaner gerade beschließen, was sie jetzt liefern oder nicht,
Sie liefern ohnehin das Allermeiste und vor allem auch somit das Allerwichtigste äh bisher und sicherlich ist die Unterstützung, die Deutschland derzeit leistet, auch nicht nicht klein,
aber äh sie könnte halt auch noch,
den ganzen Konflikt weiter verkürzen. Da sind sicher eigentlich alle einig, weil es braucht jetzt einfach mal eine Rückschlagskraft, um die Russen aus diesen Gebieten zu verdrängen, weil man will sie dort nicht haben und man will auch nicht, dass sie weiter vorrücken, also bleibt.
Unterm Strich ja eigentlich auch nix anderes, ne.
Ja ein anderer Punkt ist auch, wenn man sich anguckt so die ganze Logistik, die man in den USA müssen halt.
Ziemlich viele Sachen einfach über den Teich schaffen und äh so einen Panzer.
Equipment äh mit Ersatzteilen und was man halt sonst noch braucht, bringt halt dann irgendwie, weiß nicht, 60, 70, 80 Tonnen äh auf die Waage und,
Dafür kann man dann vielleicht erstmal anderes Zeugs ähm rüberschaffen, weil ich habe mal versucht,
auszurechnen, wie viel denn so pro Tag äh in die Ukraine geliefert wird,
und äh bin auf äh mehrere 100 LKW Ladungen gestoßen, also größenordnungsmäßig, glaube ich, waren das 1.000 Tonnen pro Tag, äh die da.
Geliefert werden, ja? Und das ist natürlich schon auch eine eine heftige Nummer, so und.
Von daher äh denke ich mal ist das eben auch ein Punkt plus, das natürlich diese diese Panzer äh.
Ja die brauchen auch entsprechend Support.
Ausbildung und da hängt ja ein ganz harten Schwanz auch noch dran. Das könnten wir äh könnten wir ganz gut vorstellen, dass hier Amerikaner da einfach nach Nutzen priorisieren, weil es dort einfach auch Bottle Next gibt und sich überlegen, was können wir
mit den durch die vorhandenen Logistik Pipelines, die wir haben, äh so äh am optimalsten durchschieben und
äh Panzer sind da nicht nicht auf der Liste bisher, ne.
Ja, aber sie könnten sie halt für für die Deutschen schon sein, zumal sie es ja noch nicht mal selber liefern müssten, so. Klagen immer über eigenen äh Bestände, aber es gibt ja durchaus noch
Panzer, die äh noch irgendwo bei den Herstellern rumstehen, beziehungsweise im Falle von Spanien, die ja schon gesagt haben, so ja, wir haben hier Leopard Panzer, könnt ihr haben und die im Übrigen.
Spanien hat mehr als die Bundeswehr. Ihr Leopard zwei Panzern, ja.
Okay, aber die haben zumindest verstanden, dass sie jetzt nicht unbedingt so an der Front sind, ja, dass sie jetzt die morgen unbedingt brauchen würden und das Argument Deutschlands, ja wir müssen ja erstmal für unsere eigene Verteidigung sorgen.
Ist halt auch irgendwie echt total Bogos, weil ich meine, es ist einfach mal vollkommen unrealistisch, dass wir in irgendeiner absehbaren Zeit.
Unserer eigenen Panzer auf eigenem Land in diesem Konflikt zum Einsatz bringen müssten, ja, weil da ist dann halt,
Mylop Polen dazwischen und Tschechien dazwischen und überhaupt und wenn's überhaupt so weit kommt, dann äh ist ohnehin die ganze NATO am Start. Also das ist einfach vollkommenes Idiotenargument und das sich dann eben,
Deutschland dagegen ausspricht, dass Spanien Panzer liefert. Ja, wo sie selber, also es geht nicht um ihr Equipment, nicht ihr Geld, so?
Gut, vielleicht sind sie dann involviert, was die ganze äh Logistik betrifft und und und äh vielleicht auch das Aufbauen dieser ganzen Kette und dann auch sagen, ja aber das würde ja auch alles viel zu lange dauern. Ich meine, das sagen sie jetzt auch schon seit sechs Monaten.
Haben ja gesehen, wie gut die Ukraine in der Lage ist, äh gerät, von dem sie bis vor Kurzem noch nix gesehen haben.
Ja wirklich gut zur Anwendung zu bringen. Ohnehin total absurd, wenn man's mal klar macht,
Also die Ukraine hat viel zu wenig, arbeitet aber irgendwie mit diesem modernen Gerät, was sie bis vor kurzem noch gar nicht kannten, was komplett inkompatibel ist zu all dem Zeug, was mit dem sie bisher gearbeitet haben.
Und was vor allem militärstrategisch und militärtechnisch äh.
Eigentlich alles so Zeug ist, was eben im Verbund mit vielen anderen Dingen, wie zum Beispiel einer schlagkräftigen Luftabwehr äh gedacht ist so und schafft es, damit irgendwie den Russen jetzt schon empfindliche Niederlagen,
Man mag sich gar nicht vorstellen, wo wir jetzt schon wären, wenn eben diese Aufrüstung noch sehr viel schneller vonstatten gegangen wäre.
Das ist irgendwie das, was ich nicht verstehe.
Ja ähm ich meine, die andere Sache, was mir noch aufgefallen ist, ich weiß nicht, ob du ähm.
Mitbekommen hast, unser Generalinspekteur der Bundeswehr, unser Rang höchster Soldat äh.
Eberhard Zorn äh so wie der sich halt äh auch geäußert.
Öffentlich äh und man eigentlich genau wie sein sein Vorgänger auch, der hat dann eigentlich wilde Szenarien aufgemacht äh oder erwähnt, was die Russen denn alles so Böses,
tun könnten und weswegen wir äh ja eben die.
Bundeswehr brauchen, weil sie könnten ja dann von Kaliningrad aus einfallen und sie könnten von dort einfallen und sie könnten hier die NATO angreifen und sie könnten das bombardieren und so und deswegen also ich dachte mir, mein Gott,
Was was redet der daher? Klar.
Dit stimmt alles äh und natürlich ist es auch so, äh dass.
Soldaten in der Regel diejenigen sind, die am wenigsten Bock auf Krieg haben, ja aus verständlichen Gründen. So generell.
Aber äh ich sage mal, wenn wenn das derjenige ist, der dann auch die Politik berät, so dann äh war mein Eindruck äh die haben alle die Hosen gestrichen voll.
Ja? Mag jetzt sagen, okay.
Vielleicht haben Sie am Ende recht, beziehungsweise die Situation ist gefährlich so, keine Frage, kann man auch noch äh später äh dazu oder gleich dazu.
Aber äh dieser Tenor, der da aus dem Bundesverteidigungsministerium kommt, ist halt wirklich so, ah nee, lass uns lass uns bloß mit dem Krieg in Ruhe. Ja, machen wir nix mit zu tun haben und äh.
Also.
Die Reaktionen auf diese Kommentare von Zorn, die waren schon irgendwie auch.
Ziemlich deutlich hier irgendwie einer schrieb, das Vertrauen in Deutschland ist ohnehin nicht sehr groß, um es vorsichtig auszudrücken, ich verstehe dich, warum die Deutschen es noch schlimmer machen.
Schreibt ein Gustav Kessel vom European Council of Forean Relations, ja.
Aber sein sein Vorgänger war da irgendwie auch nicht anders. Ich meine, das ist halt irgendwie gute Tradition, dann offensichtlich dann in der Bundeswehr ganz oben auf der äh Ebene dann Pazifisten zu haben, ja.
Oder Angsthasen, wie auch immer, äh man das äh sehen mag, aber so ist es halt nun mal.
Lieber da drauf, was ähm jetzt an Waffenlieferungen tatsächlich kommt. Da hat sich ja durchaus was äh getan,
Abgesehen davon, dass halt nach wie vor das, was hier schon bisher zum Einsatz kam, weiter äh geliefert wird und sich die Situation da zumindest nicht verschlechtert. Ähm.
Und die ganze Diskussion äh um diese äh Attac MS Munition, die wir ja schon erwähnt hatten, noch läuft ähm,
Jetzt wohl schon äh einige interessante Bewegungen und auch so ein paar Eigenentwicklungen auch von der Ukraine.
Was jetzt wohl auf jeden Fall ähm zum Einsatz gekommen schon ist, sind diese sogenannten Excalibur äh Artilleriemunitionen.
Also mit den bestehenden Haubitzen zum Einsatz gebracht werden kann. Das ist sehr interessant, weil das sind eben so selbst lenkende Munition.
Die äh so mit GPS und äh ja eigener eigenen Flügelchen sozusagen ausgestattet ist. Sie wird also zwar von der Haubitze rausgeballert, aber dann steuern die sich irgendwie selber ins Ziel,
kommen wohl schon zum Einsatz. Das wurde zumindest mehrfach bestätigt.
Ja äh Selensky hat jetzt auch bekannt gegeben, dass dieses Nasanssystem wohl.
Geliefert werden würde. Es hieß, sie hätten sie schon empfangen. Jetzt wurde da gerade zurück und meint so, ja, nee, wäre noch gar nicht da, aber kommt.
Bisschen merkwürdig. Normalerweise ist er bei der Kommunikation von solchen Sachen immer relativ klar und ähm ja, gibt auch.
Paar Gerüchte, was sich die äh Ukraine alles so noch äh einfallen lässt, um irgendwie ihre eigenen Systeme zu verbessern, äh unter anderem so ein Drohnenbasiertes Sensor-Netzwerk.
Mit dem sie äh quasi diese diese Menpads, also diese äh tragbaren.
Luftabwehrkanonen miteinander vernetzen sozusagen, also so automatische,
von Luftbewegung, von Flugzeugen et cetera, die sie über Drohnen einfangen und dann irgendwie eine automatische Aktivierung von diesen
keine Ahnung, das ist irgendwie auch jetzt alles ein bisschen wenig unterfüttert mit äh technischen Details, aber das sind so so Entwicklungen, die sich bewegen. Und dann gab's ja auch noch dieses autonome Boot, was da irgendwie ein Silvesterpol aufgelaufen ist. Hast du das gesehen?
Was äh ja wo alle vermuten, dass das irgendwie von der Ukraine gebaut ist, also quasi so eine Art Bootsdrohne.
Brot, was irgendwie durch die Gegend äh fährt und mit Summe auf Gimbals montierten Kameras und elektrischen Motor und Starling-Antenne ausgerüstet ist und.
Wohl dafür gedacht war, irgendwelche großen Schiffe zu rammen, das ist ihnen wohl ein bisschen vom Weg abgekommen und äh ja, wurde dann von den Russen.
Wasser zum explodieren gebracht.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt's jetzt äh leider auch diese neuen Kamikaze Drohnen aus dem Iran, die sich die Russen beschafft haben.
In äh großer Menge, weil die kommen jetzt auch schon zum Einsatz. Und das sind halt so, ja, Kamikaze Drohnen, also die können so vom Lastwagen losfliegen.
Und können auch einen relativ großen Range, paarhundert Kilometer äh überbrücken und fliegen dann halt irgendwie ins Ziel. Und damit greifen sie jetzt verschiedene Ziele an, unter anderem halt auch äh in Odessa.
Aber insgesamt scheint es ganz gut zu laufen. Also die Zahl der abgeschossenen Flugzeuge zum Beispiel.
In den letzten Tagen war extrem hoch. Also der Russen.
Gerade da haben sie irgendwie an einem Tag irgendwie vier Flugzeuge eingebüßt, also das scheint für die da nicht so gut zu laufen.
Ja wenn auch.
Beim Material noch mal fällt mir, fällt mir ein, also die die Mengen, die da teilweise äh geliefert werden, sind halt äh signifikant.
So äh auch an an Munition äh jetzt, also nicht nur neue Spielzeuge.
Angeht, äh sondern einfach man rechnet damit, dass es äh zum Beispiel äh ja in die Größenordnung äh von eine Millionen äh hundert äh,
55 Millimeter äh Granaten ja Artilleriegranaten.
Äh geliefert äh worden sind oder sich sich in Lieferung befinden. So und ähm.
Ja äh und Größenordnungsmäßig zehntausend äh.
Raketen äh für eben Eimaß oder generell äh diese Maß äh Systeme und so. Das heißt,
Das äh kommt jetzt dann auch noch mal dazu, dass das jetzt.
So die Dinger, die nicht so spektakulär sind äh eben auch anlaufen oder angelaufen äh sind und jetzt in größeren Mengen dort Zeugs ankommt.
Das noch.
Das Ganze Ateliermaterial, was die Russen jetzt zurückgelassen haben, was sie dann mit ihren ähm Haubitzen russischer Bauer hat äh verwende.
Wobei es da gab's dann auch noch diese nette Anekdote, dass.
Irgendwie plötzlich scheinbar, wenn ich chinesische Munition gefunden wurde. Ähm,
bei der Offensive erobert und da stellte sich dann aber raus, nachdem dann erstmal, oh, die Chinesen liefern ja jetzt Munition an die Russen. Das ist eigentlich ursprünglich,
Ukrainische Munition war, weil vom Kaliber her haben die Russen sowas nicht äh und die ist halt,
quasi beim Einmarsch der der russischen
Truppen in deren Hände gefallen, aber die wussten nicht so richtig, was sie damit anfangen sollen und jetzt bei der Gegenoffensive haben die Ukrainer die wieder ihre eigene Munition auch wieder zurückbeobacht. So äh.
Fand ich auch noch.
Die chinesischen Schriftzeichen drauf.
Mhm, mhm.
Also wodurch kam die da drauf?
Na ja, weil ursprünglich die Ukraine das mal von China gekauft hat.
Ach so. Das waren 155 Millimeter oder.
Nee, nee, das waren irgendwie kleinere Kaliber. Das waren dann das waren dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, sechzig Millimetergranaten oder so Haubitzengranaten oder äh ja beim Mörsergranaten, glaube ich sogar.
Na gut, gut. Schließe mal den äh Teil auch mal ab und komme mal vielleicht hier zu unserem letzten großen äh Segment. Du hast ja ein paar Gedanken gemacht zu Qualität versus Quantität.
So ja, äh irgendwann kam plötzlich die Frage auf, also im Zusammenhang jetzt natürlich mit der russischen.
Mobilmachung äh und Russlands Größe und dass die da jetzt offensichtlich gewillt sind richtig Manpower reinzuhauen, was zumindest zu versuchen und.
Ist wahrscheinlich auch gelingen äh wird so war für mich die Frage, okay was ist denn jetzt so das Verhältnis zwischen Qualität und Quantität im im Krieg, weil,
Auch im Zweiten Weltkrieg weiß man ja eigentlich die deutschen Waffen und Panzer waren halt alle qualitativ,
besser als die russischen, aber die Russisch. Die Russen hatten halt mehr davon.
Und äh Stalin sagte dann eben auch äh so schön, ja Qualität hat seine eigene äh äh Quantität hat seine eigene Qualität und da.
Einfach mal wissen, was ist denn darüber bekannt? So äh wie,
wie ist das äh wenn ich für dasselbe Geld äh weiß ich nicht,
meine Effizienz verdoppeln kann oder meine äh doppelt so viele Leute einsetzen kann, was hat am am Ende hm mehr Effekt und.
Erstmal kann man sagen Qualität und Quantität äh,
jeder Unterschied in Qualität kann halt durch einen Unterschied in Quantität ausgeglichen werden und umgekehrt. Bis zu einer gewissen Grenze äh äh würde ich,
würde ich sagen. Das heißt, klar, wenn ich bessere Truppen habe, brauche ich weniger für denselben Effekt und wenn ich schlechtere Truppen habe, brauche ich mehr. So, aber ich,
kann das halt ausgleichen, aber wollte dann wissen, okay wie, aber wie ist das denn jetzt, wenn ich das jetzt mal versuche, mathematisch oder in in Zahlen zu fassen und.
Hm diese eigene Qualität der Quantität.
Ist tatsächlich auch mathematisch, ganz einfach zu finden und,
nimmt man jetzt setzt man jetzt Qualität mit Effizienz gleich, also Effizienz im Töten. Beispielsweise ist die Frage okay ähm.
Wenn jetzt der Gegner wie gesagt doppelt so viele Leute hat äh und ich,
selber aber doppelt so effizient bin so äh was passiert denn dann, wenn diese Truppen dann aufeinander treffen. Ich sage mal meine hunderttausend äh Leute, die.
Doppelt so effizient sind wie die zweihunderttausend, die nicht gegenüberstehe und in dem Fall sagen würde die Effizienz gemessen, wie viele Leute brauche ich, um bei einem Aufeinandertreffen einen Gegner zu töten,
ja? Wenn man die effizientere braucht halt nur fünf Leute,
die weniger effiziente braucht halt zehn Leute, um dieselbe Wirkung äh beim Gegner äh zu erreichen und wenn ich dann jetzt halt diese beiden aber aufeinander.
Treffen lasse, äh stelle ich halt ganz schnell,
festgenommen hat, Tabellenkalkulation machen, dass bei jedem Aufeinandertreffen dann sagen, jetzt die einen,
es schaffen, wegen, weil sie doppelt so effizient sind, ich sage mal 20tausend,
äh von der anderen Seite auszuschalten und die anderen schaffen auch 2000 von der anderen Seite auszuschalten. Nur ist halt dann klar, die eine Seite hat halt zweihunderttausend, das heißt, ich muss nicht nicht doppelt so effizient sein.
Sondern viermal so effizient sein, äh um gegen die doppelte Zahl von Gegnern äh zu,
bestehen. Also mit anderen Worten, die äh äh Qualität der Quantität besteht eben in diesem quadratischen Verhältnis. So.
Ähm und jetzt erstmal dann denken, oh ja, also Putin oder die Russen haben da definitiv.
Irgendwie dann einen einen Vorteil, weil nimmt man jetzt hm.
An, dass äh Russland ungefähr die drei,6fache Bevölkerung hat, wie die Ukraine und.
Beide würden jetzt sagen wir mal den selber, den totalen Krieg, die totale Mobilisierung erklären und dann so fünfzig, 60 Prozent ihres Bruttoinlands äh Produkts und.
Dieselben Anteil an.
Soldaten an der Bevölkerung rekrutieren, müsste halt ein Ukrainer 13 Mal effizienter kämpfen als ein äh Russe, um gleichzuziehen.
Ja. Ähm auf der anderen Seite das wäre die Rechnung, wenn jetzt beide Länder einfach alleine,
einander gegenüberstehen, nur hat die Ukraine ja, ich sage mal den Westen,
auf der auf seiner Seite und wie du oben der Westen sind so im Moment 1,35 Milliarden Menschen, ne?
Dessen, was es an Russen gibt und ungefähr, wenn man das Bruttoinlandsprodukt nimmt, Kaufkraft bereinigt.
Zehn etwa und ansonsten ja Faktor 30 bis 40 im reinen Dollarbeträgen. So.
Also müsste wiederum.
Um gegen die NATO zu bestehen, müsste Russland also 80 bis 100 Mal effizienter kämpfen oder,
anteilig halt zehnmal so viel seines Bruttoinlandsprodukts für den Krieg aufwenden äh wie der Westen.
Also mit anderen Worten würde Russland jetzt,
totalen Krieg. Wir lassen mal das Atomat, das Atomthema lassen wir mal raus, das kommt später noch. Aber über Russland halt dann so einen totalen Krieg wie im zweiten Weltkrieg führen, also 50 bis 60Prozent seines Bruttoinlandsprodukts in
Krieg investieren, äh dann äh würde der Westen äh mit 5 bis6 Prozent seines Bruttoinlands,
quasi quantitativ erstmal gleichziehen, ja? Das heißt, wenn selbst wenn Russland sich jetzt voll verausgaben würde,
würde, müsste der Westen nochmal vielleicht, ja, seine aktuellen Anstrengungen nicht einmal verdoppeln, ja? Die USA sind jetzt bei vier Prozent, die müssten dann auf sechs Prozent steigern und dann,
Ja, würde man würde man gleichziehen, so. Aber.
Was das Ganze jetzt noch krasser macht und was für mich dann so ein bisschen ähm aufgehender Kronleuchter.
War dann die Frage, ja wie sieht es denn realistisch eigentlich aus äh mit,
Qualitäts- oder Effizienzverhältnis, man bei Truppenstärken kann man halt relativ leicht sagen, okay, der hat so und so viel Leute und Kanonen und und Panzer und so, das ist halt,
ziemlich trivial. Aber ähm was sind denn dann so realistische.
Qualitätsverhältnis, also um wie viel besser kann denn so das Militär eines Landes sein,
als ein anderes und wie ist es in vergangenen Konflikten gewesen? Dann habe ich mir erstmal angeguckt, was ist denn im Irak 2003 passiert als,
584.000 Koalitionstruppen gegen 1,3 Millionen irakische Truppen.
Angetreten sind und dabei sind, ich meine, die Zahlen sind umstritten, aber äh sind halt,
20.000irakische Soldaten getötet worden und 200 Koalitionssoldaten.
Worden und wenn man das einfach ausrechnet, dann brauchte der Irak 6500 Soldaten, um einen Angreifer zu töten.
Und die Koalition der Willigen, die zu 80 Prozent aus den USA stammten, brauchten halt 30 Soldaten, um einen Iraker zu töten. Also mit anderen Worten, die
Koalition war so rund 200 Mal effizienter beim Töten und das auch noch in der Rolle,
Angreifer, der ja dann nochmal.
Größenordnungsmäßig dreimal höhere Verluste hat oder dreimal mehr braucht. So mit anderen Worten.
Der Irak hätte statt den 1,3 Millionen Truppen, die sie hatten, 8 Millionen Truppen oder 14 Mal mehr,
Truppen als die Koalition gebraucht, um sich zu behaupten. Ja?
Ähm bei jetzt also 200 Mal effizienter, nur um sich quasi verteidigen zu können und in Wirklichkeit eben war aber die qualitative Überlegenheit, weil.
Angriff eher Faktor 600 und das hat mich dann halt schon ein bisschen erstaunt, dass eben so gigantische.
Qualitätsunterschiede bestehen und das heißt jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass jetzt wenn ich hm,
jede jedes Gewehr oder jede Kanone irgendwie sechshundert Mal besser trifft oder 6hundertmal schneller schießt oder was auch immer, sondern.
Summe aus allem.
Sondern ja, es ist zwar nicht nur die Summe, sondern das Produkt. So, das sind halt diese sogenannten.
Multiplayer und äh äh so das, was weiß ich, wenn du dann Satellitenüberwachung
mit reinbringst, sind deine vorhandenen Kräfte, wenn du die integrierst, dann schon mal wieder mal Faktor zwei oder Mal drei. Und dann
Äh ja, hast du halt ja Drohnenradarsysteme, Störsender, Sensoren, Satelliten, Software, Kommunikations- und Computersysteme, Präzisionswaffen.
Und all das multipliziert sich äh halt und so kommt man dann eben bei sage mal fair so auf solche krassen äh Qualitäts,
Unterschiede. So, die man Effektivitätsunterschiede und auch äh,
So ähm zum Beispiel Haymaß-Effekt,
mal erklärt sich dann ganz gut, also ich sage mal Heimmaß sozusagen ein Heimmaß Raketenwerfer plus gute Aufklärung.
Plus gute Ausbildung ist dann wahrscheinlich hundert oder mehr russische BM 21 Grad Raketenwerfer wert äh auf dem auf dem Schlachtfeld.
Und äh so sieht man dann ja, dass selbst auch eine relativ geringe Zahl äh.
Hochwertige Systeme ähm in den Mix reingebracht eben äh ja.
Ziemlich viel auf einmal ändern äh kann,
und ähm gut, wir haben jetzt gesehen bei bei Irak, also Koalition versus Irak war jetzt Fakt sechshundert. So hm,
bei äh Qualität NATO Russland ist schwer zu sagen, aber ich denke mal
Annahme von Faktor 1hundert durch eben entsprechende Combit Arms äh wäre jetzt nicht unrealistisch äh würde ich sagen,
und,
Auf jeden Fall ist dann dieser Qualitätsfaktor dreizehn, den ich genannt hatte am Anfang, äh den die Ukraine gegen Russland bräuchte, um gleichzuziehen, alles andere als utopisch, sondern äh den Faktor dreizehn, der ist.
Erreichbar, ja und gar nicht so schwer erreichbar durch ihn wird, Kombination verschiedener äh Systeme und hm.
Ähm bei äh jetzt
Wenn man jetzt in das Russische und das ukrainische Militär habe ich dann mal versucht zu vergleichen auch mit anhand jetzt der der Verluste und der Zahl der Truppen ist alles nicht so leicht einzuschätzen, aber
Äh ich bin, wenn ich davon ausgehe, dass irgendwie 40 bis 60.000 Tote ist bei den Kämpfern für Russland gegeben hat in den ersten beiden Phasen des Krieges
ungefähr 20.000 bis 30.000 auf Seiten des ukrainischen Militärs und,
beide Seiten auch ungefähr die gleiche Zahl von Kämpfern hatten. Wobei die.
Ukraine tendenziell äh möglicherweise mehr hatte, aber wie gesagt,
etwa ich ich glaube an Größenordnungsmäßig war es dieselbe. Dann das rechnet dann stellt man fest, dass die Ukraine.
Aber in der Verteidigerrolle war und eigentlich nur effizienter, weil sie in der Verteidigerrolle war. Das heißt,
In der ersten und zweiten Phase war Russ hatte Russland sogar leichte Qualitätsvorteile ich so irgendwie mit Faktor 1,5 bis zwei
schätzen würde, ja. Ähm deswegen sind sie dann auch erstmal äh ja,
rein und Vormarsch und hatten halt äh entsprechende äh Erfolge. Mit der Khaki äh,
Offensive, wo mich die Zahlen auch noch.
Ja erst langsam äh zutage treten. Ähm habe ich dann mal geguckt, was denn da ist, was denn auf Seiten der Ukraine dort,
angetreten ist und da wo habe ich dann 14 Brigaden gefunden plus Polizeikräfte, was so Größenordnungs wahrscheinlich 50.000 bis 60.000 Soldaten waren auf Seiten der Ukraine, die da.
In die Offensive gegangen äh sind, also äh nennenswert.
Unwahrscheinlich 4000 bis 6000 Fahrzeuge undäh die Verluste äh auf ukrainischer Seite.
Sieht so aus, als wären das hunderte bis tausende Soldaten gewesen und auch zig Fahrzeuge, äh die sie verloren haben.
Auf russischer Seite hm da hieß es ja immer dann von den Russen, oh dann irgendwie acht Mal überlegen und ähm.
Aber guckt man sich das gesamte Schlachtfeld äh an oder das gesamte,
äh
würde ich eher sagen, nachdem welche Einheiten da in der Nähe waren und eben verwickelt waren und getötet oder gefangen oder geflohen sind oder anderweitig irgendwie,
Einfluss hatten auf das Geschehen, äh,
kann man wahrscheinlich kommt man auf 30.000 bis 90.000 Soldaten, je nachdem wo man die Grenze äh zieht, ja. Das heißt äh,
im Grunde genommen waren die Kräfteverhältnisse äh.
Waren die Ukrainer zwar hatten eine höhere Konzentration an einer Stelle, aber guckt man sich die gesamten, mani, wie viel sind jetzt vier, 5000 Quadratkilometer an und zählt die Soldaten, die da stationiert waren und eben geflohen sind, dann.
Ja äh waren die Russen eigentlich sogar numerisch quantitativ in der Übermacht. So.
Ähm und da die Ukraine außerdem auch noch als Angreifer den Erschwernisfaktor drei hatten ähm.
Kommt man dann auf eine äh vermutlich auf eine,
äh qualitative Überlegenheit äh von Faktor 6 bis 15 irgendwo oder vielleicht Faktor ziehen als realistische Annahme.
Und,
Wenn es der Ukraine jetzt gelingen würde, diesen Faktor zehn generell für seine gesamten Streitkräfte oder für einen Großteil.
Auch zu realisieren, dann würde das bedeuten, dass bei gleicher Zahl von Kräften.
Die Ukraine angreifen kann.
Gleichen Verlusten wie die Verteidiger, ja, was schon mal.
Gut ist so, weil äh ja ähm,
oder wenn sie die Ukraine in der Rolle als Verteidiger wäre mit dieser Qualität, dass sie dann,
dreifachen Übermacht mit einem Drittel der Verluste standhalten kann. Er eingangs gesagt, okay,
einem totalen Krieg, also rüsten könnten vielleicht jetzt die dreifache numerische Übermacht produzieren, aber äh wenn die Ukraine dann wieder in die Defensive gehen, dann könnten sie diese dreifache Übermacht mit einem Drittel der Verluste.
Werden so. Mit anderen Worten zusammengefasst.
Ohne Qualität kann Russland nicht gewinnen, ja, weil es einfach nicht diese numerische Übermacht hat äh beziehungsweise die Ukraine jetzt qualitativ,
eben so viel äh besser geworden ist äh und dass wenn Russland nicht auf Qualität setzt, ähm.
Ja äh,
kann sie so viel toppen, gar nicht aufbieten, um gewinnen äh zu können, sondern sagt wird dann halt dreimal so viele Verluste haben als,
Angreifer äh mit dreimal so viel Truppen und äh trotzdem nicht vorankommen. So,
Das Problem natürlich, also erstens sieht's nicht so aus äh.
Dass äh die Russen gerade irgendwie auf Qualität setzen würden, weil.
Wiederum jetzt die andere Ökonomie zwischen äh äh Qualität und äh Quantität ist noch die, dass ich Quantität.
Oft schneller produzieren kann oder in der Regel eben schneller verfügbar ist, während Qualität halt lange Vorbereitung,
und vorab Investitionen erfordert. Also ich muss halt tolle Waffen entwickeln und testen und ich muss meine Truppen ausbilden und ich muss die im Zusammenspiel äh trainieren und,
Äh ja das ist also.
Die die eine Seite plus das ist natürlich warum halt auch die Natur auf Qualität gesetzt hat oder generell eher Armeen auf Qualität setzen ist, dass die natürlich im Frieden viel billiger,
zu erhalten ist als jetzt äh Quantität, weil wenn ich jetzt ganz viele Truppen,
habe und die dauernd die ganze Zeit bezahlen äh muss oder das ja das das wächst halt irgendwie sehr schnell Plus im Quantität hat halt.
Festere, obere Limits. So ich kann einfach nur so und so viel,
und Truppen und so produzieren. Irgendwann ist Schluss. Wären.
Bei der qualitativen Überlegenheit keine Obergrenze gibt, ja. Da kann ich halt,
beliebig warnste Waffen, die mir auch, wie man sieht, oder
in Kombination dann den Militär aufbauen, was hundert, zweihundert, fünfhundert, tausendfach überlegen ist, qualitativ und,
Das ist dann zwar nur die die Wurzel, also wenn ich äh.
Wenn ich hundert Mal, wie gesagt, hundertmal bessere Truppen habe, ähm so kann der Gegner das.
Zehnmal so viel kompensieren, aber zehnmal so viel ist halt dann auch mal zehnmal so teuer und insofern egal äh wie rum man das halt halt rechnet äh,
ohne Qualität wird's Russland mit Quantität nicht schaffen, aber um Qualität,
zu produzieren bräuchte es im besten Fall 6 bis24 Monate Zeithorizont um wahrscheinlich überhaupt nur mithalten.
Zu können mit der äh Ukraine oder den Qualitätsverbesserungen und äh ich sehe nicht, dass Russland äh zu Hause,
so viel Zeit hat und dass es eben auch der Grund, warum sie jetzt nichts wirklich anderes können als auf äh,
Quantität zu setzen im Moment, weil ja für Qualität ist nicht die Zeit da. Es fehlen,
auch die Grundlagen plus Sanktionen und Ähnliches, also die Sanktionen bekommen unter dem Aspekt halt auch nochmal eine besondere Bedeutung, weil sie natürlich auch verhindern, dass Russland äh die Qualität,
steigert und äh ja aus meiner Sicht ja hat Russland eigentlich keine Chance, ja.
So also die Mathematik spricht.
Zeigt es klar.
Zeigt es klar, dass äh.
In Wirklichkeit ist natürlich alles äh äh komplizierter, aber ich habe die Rechnung auch deswegen aufgemacht, weil halt natürlich immer viele Leute kommen, ja Russland, groß, mächtig äh.
Und so und gegen diese russischen Horden äh so wie soll sich da die kleine Ukraine zu äh äh zur Wehr setzen, aber wie gesagt ja Qualität ist halt.
Heißt es so schön im äh durch die Galaxis äh da bewies der Mensch das schwarz äh weil es halt gerade alles gerade sich so schön ausgerechnet hat äh bewies er noch äh bewies der Mensch dann dass es noch schwarz gleich weiß war und kam zehn Minuten später auf dem Zebrastreifen.
Ähm aber ich verstehe natürlich,
für das äh bemerkenswert, wie du das jetzt mal alles äh durchgerechnet hast. Es ist natürlich so, dass jetzt wirklich.
Auch absehbar ist, dass sowohl die Qualität bei der Ukraine noch weiter steigert, weil noch bessere Ausbildungen, noch bessere Waffensysteme, noch bessere Combind abends Initiativen et cetera, die werden auch nicht schlechter die ganze Zeit, während es halt bei den Russen
genau andersrum aussieht. Keine Möglichkeit hier auch nur,
nur die Quantität noch nennenswert zu erhöhen, weil ich meine, alles, was sie jetzt noch quantitativ nachliefern in Form von Personal, ist dann wiederum qualitativ sehr schlecht.
Gleiche gilt halt auch für Equipment.
Sie können bestimmt locker irgendwie theoretisch, weiß nicht, 5 oder zehn Millionen Leute barfuß äh über die Grenze.
Stöckern bewaffnet, ja.
Ja mit Knüppeln und äh keine Ahnung mit Knüppeln und Messern bewaffnet äh so Chinesen haben das teilweise auch auch so äh,
gemacht und das hat dann durchaus auch erstmal funktioniert in Korea beispielsweise. So also insofern.
Dass das so zielführend wäre, ne.
Nee.
Funktioniert halt heutzutage auch aus dem Grund nicht, weil in den meisten Ländern eben die Geburten raten äh niedrig sind, weshalb wiederum die Gesellschaft,
die wenigen Kinder viel mehr Geld investiert und die Toleranz äh jetzt äh viele.
Tote oder Opfer in Kauf zu nehmen, hat sich gegenüber, ich sage mal jetzt, dem zweiten Weltkrieg oder auch den fünfziger oder sechziger Jahren äh auch noch mal,
radikal äh gewandelt, das heißt Russland hat,
gar nicht irgendwie äh diese diese Zahl von Truppen wie vorher oder wie wie wie früher oder wie in der Sowjetunion. Also als Beispiel.
Erwähnt, auch in der letzten Sendung gab's ja diese deutsche Offensive äh auch bei äh Shakif, äh Khakow, das hieß dann irgendwie, ja, die Schlacht bei Carkov.
Und äh die lief fast genauso.
So stellungsmäßig, selbe Gegend, selber Durchbruch der Wehrmacht letzte große deutsche Kesselschlacht. Und nur zum Vergleich dabei äh hat die Sowjetarmee 200.000 Soldaten.
Und das ist heutzutage ja wäre das wahrscheinlich also wenn.
Man es sind natürlich auch deutlich weniger äh Truppen jetzt, die da aufeinander treffen, aber,
Ja, es ist eben auch nicht mehr nicht mehr wie früher. Du kannst heute nicht mehr so kämpfen wie im zweiten Weltkrieg. Aber die Russen scheinen das noch nicht so ganz begriffen.
Zu haben, dass das nicht zielführend ist.
Also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass äh sie jetzt schon teilweise an dem Punkt angekommen sind, wo sie verstehen, dass es eigentlich vorbei ist und jetzt ist halt die Frage, was äh passiert jetzt dadran?
Ne? Ich glaube Putin war die Russen glauben noch, wie gesagt, also die glauben noch nicht, dass sie verlieren könnten. So, ich glaube äh sie sind jetzt hm?
Wer.
Der Großteil der Russen glaubt nicht, dass sie verlieren.
Also der Bevölkerung.
Bevölkerung und auch der Führung. So. Ja, weil das.
Also ich glaube bei der Armee äh sieht das schon wieder anders aus.
Ja, ja, also ich glaube bei denen, die vor oder viele von denen, die so vor Ort sind oder oder über diese, aber selbst da gehen sie davon aus, na ja gut,
Okay, wir haben jetzt mit quasi mit äh,
auf dem Rücken gefesselten Händen kämpfen müssen, weil das war ja kein Krieg, sondern nur eine Spezialoperation und deswegen,
mir nicht die notwendigen ja Ressourcen zur Verfügung und konnten nicht wirklich das das tun. Ja es war teilweise auch so,
aber äh so und deswegen ist jetzt der Glaube, okay, wir haben noch gar nicht richtig angefangen so. Wir schicken jetzt jetzt machen wir halt
erst richtig Krieg und dann hat die Ukraine keinen Schnitt. Ich meine, das ist was, das war dieselbe Argumentation auch, die ich auch aus dem Westen, was weiß ich vom Generalinspekteur der Bundeswehr.
Gehört habe oder auch ganz viele Leute im Westen glauben das und in Russland erst recht ist, also der die Vorstellung, dass Russland,
gegen die Ukraine verlieren könnte so, das ist äh ist so wie wenn keine Ahnung äh,
Ich sage mal, Dänemark jetzt äh.
Also in einem in einem militärischen Konflikt zwischen, wenn ich jetzt Dänemark und Deutschland oder Österreich und Deutschland wäre vielleicht auch dass dort irgendwie,
Ja, die Österreicher oder die Dänen jetzt gewinnen könnten absurd. Ja, absurde Vorstellung.
So absurd finde ich das jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht. Bei der Get your Point, ne? Das ist dieser Unbesiegbarkeitsmytho ist natürlich der ja auch.
Von Putin auch medial in unsere Gesellschaften getragen worden ist. So das ist ja auch so Teil dieser ganzen äh
Offensive auf die Hirne gewesen, auch immer dieses Bild eines unglaublich starken Russlands zu präsentieren und wir haben's halt auch einfach gefressen und wir sind davon ausgegangen, dass es halt einfach irgendwie so ist bis hin zu den Militärexperten.
Alle am Anfang dieses Krieges gesagt haben äh pff kannst du vergessen, irgendwie Frage der Zeit so und dann saß nach einer Woche schon mal anders aus und äh,
auch zum Zeitpunkt der,
starken Donbass-Offensive kam das ja noch oft. So und jetzt geht's aber richtig los und jetzt haben sie äh aus ihren Fehlern gelernt und jetzt äh wenn sie ihre Übermacht so richtig ausnutzen und keiner hat gesehen, dass die Ukraine schon voll,
im taktischen Modus unterwegs war, sich einfach gesagt hat, ja wir reiben euch jetzt hier mal. Ihr reibt euch jetzt mal schön an uns
So wir halten jetzt diese Stellung. Das können wir irgendwie gut verteidigen. Hier sind wir Fortified und wir ähm fügen euch starke Verluste zu und danach kommt eine Kriegsliste in und danach äh gibt's richtig auch für Oma.
So läuft's halt.
Ja ich ich erinnere mich, dass wir ich glaube sogar in der ersten Sendung, die wir zur Ukraine gemacht haben äh äh,
da gesessen, das das kann irgendwie mathematisch nicht aufgehen so mit einer Zahl der Truppen auf beiden
Seiten, ja? Da war mir das dieses Qualitätsquantitätsverhältnis nicht so ganz klar, sondern nur war halt so okay, eigentlich als Angreifer brauchst du die dreifache Zahl an,
an Truppen und die Ukrainer haben eben äh,
nicht nicht so viele so beziehungsweise äh nein äh da war es halt offensichtlich, dass.
Die Russen nicht die dreifache nummerische Überlegenheit haben und hätten dafür eben dann.
Nochmal entsprechende qualitative Überlegenheit haben müssen, wie wir jetzt wissen irgendwie noch mal hätte Faktor zehn besser sein müssen und das war's nicht und das reichte halt deswegen
äh äh nicht und ja so kam's dann am Ende auch. Es hat halt einfach nicht gereicht. Äh,
es ist nicht sichtbar, dass es irgendwie überhaupt,
noch reichen wird, weil äh jetzt das Großteil des Potenzials, der auch da war an an Waffen, an Waffensystemen, an ausgebildeten Leuten äh,
ist ja vernichtet oder geschwächt oder oder oder zerstört, das heißt,
äh allein nur um das zu äh zu regenerieren, was,
anfangen äh äh der der Invasion vorhanden war äh äh dürfte sehr sehr schwierig äh werden.
So. Ja, womit wir, glaube ich, fast schon ja, nicht ganz am Ende wären, weil einen haben wir noch auf jeden Fall. Nämlich jetzt die nuklearen Drohungen.
Wo wir ja auch.
Mehrfach in den letzten Sendungen gesagt hatten. Ja das sind das ist das ist sind blass. Die sind nicht ernst zu nehmen, weil äh,
Ja ähm so einfach.
Ist es halt nicht und da hat sich jetzt ein kleines Stück geändert jetzt, weil hm.
Die letzten Drohungen von Putin waren so formuliert, dass die.
Erstmalig glaube ich wirklich ernst genommen werden. Also man hat das nie so ganz auf die leichte Schulter genommen, aber eigentlich war das immer ähm irgendwie das ist halt ist halt Gerede,
Aber äh diesmal war's so und es gab Vermutungen auch, dass hm.
Der Grund, warum Putin seine Rede auf den nächsten Morgen verschoben hat. Ursprünglich waren die ja für 8 Uhr angekündigt, dann auf neun, dann wird's gecancelt und dann hat er am nächsten Morgen ja diese Rede gehalten. Äh da gab's die Vermutung,
dass ähm ähm.
Sie noch gefeilt haben an der atomaren Drohung, an der nuklearen Drohung, wie sie das am überzeugendsten,
rüber am Rücken und im Gegensatz zu, ich sage mal vorher teilweise oder wurde dann offen von Atomwaffen die Rede war, äh war diesmal nur die Rede von,
ähm alle verfügbaren Mittel, ja, einzusetzen, so und ähm.
Das war so ein bisschen so der der Punkt, wo man das geführte, okay also in Verbindung mit dem jetzt mit der Mobilisierung äh war dann auch klar, dass.
Die Mobilisierung, wenn die nicht gut geht, dass dann äh sagen die nukleare äh Drohung oder dass dann dass da eine weitere Eskalation, dass das dann der weitere Eskalationsschritt ist, weil mehr bleibt halt nicht.
Ja? Wenn wenn jetzt ist klar, wenn ja, wenn jetzt die Mobilisierung bis ja.
Frühjahr nicht funktioniert, dann äh bleiben Putin nur noch Atomwaffen und.
Hm ja damit ist zwar der Atomkrieg derzeit noch unwahrscheinlich aber äh.
Dem, was jetzt passiert ist mit der Mobilisierung.
So stehen jetzt, muss man sagen, die Weichen stehen jetzt auf Atomkrieg und wir steuern drauf zu.
Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass es jetzt unabwendbar ist aber wenn das jetzt einfach nur so läuft,
wie es jetzt läuft und nicht irgendwie oder wie es wahrscheinlich laufen wird, dann äh äh werden wir sehr wahrscheinlich äh.
In einem Atomkrieg landen und so die Schritte, die ich da sehe ist, ja, Russland wird halt jetzt die Teile der Ukraine annektieren. Russland wird sie nicht halten können.
Putin wird dann irgendwann vor die Wahl gestellt sein aufzugeben.
Oder zu eskalieren. Die einzige Eskalationsmöglichkeit sind taktische Atomwaffen und.
Putin ist nicht ein Typ, der irgendwie aufgibt, ja?
Wenn das passiert, ne wird.
Wir derzeit. Denken wir derzeit.
Ja aber äh.
Ja also das kann man halt schon aus aus der Vergangenheit, in der Vergangenheit hat man das oft gesehen und.
Jetzt äh ist der Einsatz gesagt so groß, äh den er da jetzt äh sehr pott,
was da auf dem Tisch liegt hat sich jetzt so sehr vergrößert, dass hm es sehr eben sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich ist, dass er
Ja es versuchen wird quasi dann wenn er wenn er nicht mehr weiterkommt mit Hilfe von taktischen Atomwaffen äh zu
eskalieren in der Hoffnung, dass dann alle sagen, oh mein Gott, das geht aber jetzt weit, jetzt müssen wir doch irgendwie reden und verhandeln und äh.
Das ist quasi sein äh seine letzte Karte, die er, die er noch hat.
Ähm so und wenn das passiert, aber es auch,
relativ wahrscheinlich oder ist jetzt ja irgendwie klargeworden, wie,
wahrscheinlichste Antwort äh der USA aussehen wird auf so eine Provokation mit taktischen,
Atomwaffen. Äh die dann wahrscheinlich gegen den Ziel in der Ukraine eingesetzt würden, wahrscheinlich gegen ein militärisches Ziel.
Es könnte auch eine reine Demonstration sein, je nachdem, aber äh wenn äh jetzt die Russen,
eine Atomwaffe gegen die Ukraine einsetzen, das ist das wahrscheinlichste Ziel sein wird,
Wird die Antwort der USA wohl eine weitgehende konventionelle Zerstörung der russischen Truppen in der Ukraine sein?
Ja das ist das ist das wahrscheinlichste Szenario.
Warum ist das das wahrscheinlichste Szenario? Ich meine, dass das Problem mit dem Szenario ist, es würde sehr lange dauern, bis diese Truppenkonzentration also das wäre ja dann ein Aufmarsch, der dann nochmal mindestens drei, vier Wochen dauern würde.
Mindestens, wenn nicht länger. Und das ist nicht unbedingt das, was jetzt die USA als sofortige Reaktion äh verstehen würde.
Ich denke mal, man wird,
also wir werden das ja beobachten äh können, wenn wir und ich denke mal äh wenn absehbar ist, dass äh ja.
Krieg für äh Russland dann tatsächlich äh weiter so schlecht läuft,
äh so äh wird man, gehe ich mal davon aus, äh,
wird man weitere Truppen äh in Stellung äh bringen und die USA kann auch äh durchaus aus der Ferne ähm sozusagen dort dann entsprechend an,
greifen, also die müssen da jetzt nicht mit Bodentruppen,
rein, sondern es würde dann so ein bisschen aussehen wahrscheinlich wie das Szenario dann die ersten zwei Wochen so im äh,
ja dersert äh storm oder so wo erstmal
komplett die gesamte Logistik und äh Kommunikation und äh alles, was irgendwo, von dem man weiß, wo es ist, äh äh würde dann halt,
angegriffen,
werden und realistisch betrachtet die Russen äh jetzt dann auch nicht wirklich eine Möglichkeit äh das zu verhindern.
Außer dann wiederum mit atomaren Angriffen auf die NATO zu antworten,
woraufhin äh dann äh wieder mögliche oder
am wahrscheinlichsten eine Antwort wäre äh.
In Mode gekommen ist, die die nuclear retaliation
versucht dann mit einem atomaren Schlag so das russische Militär und die russische Führung komplett auszuschalten,
So, das ist sozusagen,
im Moment aus meiner Sicht der wahrscheinlichste Weg, so wenn's wenn's man's jetzt einfach laufen lässt, so wie's jetzt läuft, so. Ähm sehe ich, dass äh ja wie wie das so ist, geht.
Passieren halt Dinge so, die eigentlich keiner will, aber äh sagen in der Logik der Abfolge einzelner Schritte ähm,
zumal was dazukommt, ist das sowohl äh Russland als auch in den in den USA die Stimmen, die einen Atomkrieg für führbar und gewinnbar halten. Ähm.
Ja äh an an Stärke gewonnen haben, so würde ich da würde ich das mal ausdrücken.
Und.
Man natürlich will das niemand und keiner weiß wie katastrophal äh das das Ganze wäre. Ähm das Ende der Welt wär's nicht, aber ähm,
so die Welt wäre sicherlich äh eine.
Also okay, ich will da mal ein paar.
Mhm. Was ist denn ja.
Meine meine optimistische Perspektive. Also ich habe da starke Zweifel äh äh dran, weil dann würde er sich ja sozusagen davon versprechen, dass er damit irgendwie seine Ziele durchsetzen kann.
Ich glaube, dass das ähm gut, keine Ahnung, in welchem mentalen Zustand sich dieser Mensch äh befindet. Aber ich denke äh mal,
rational drüber nachgedacht. Ich meine, in dem Moment, wo er irgendwie eine taktische New dort zündet.
Mit nichts anderem rechnen als der totalen Zerstörung, insbesondere äh von sich selbst. Und das das ist sozusagen einfach die Folge. Also man ist doch vollkommen klar,
danach die Antwort einfach maximal sein wird.
Sein Kalkül ist oder seine Einschätzung, das ist ja überhaupt das das Problem, weswegen dieser Krieg überhaupt entstanden ist, ist.
Der Westen nichts macht.
Das das Putin den Westen unterschätz,
Ich meine, es ist auch wieder dieses Paradox auf der einen Seite
ja? Ist Russland ja in Gefahr durch den Westen, der Russland irgendwie ja,
will und durch die NATO-Expansion ja, dann weiß ich nicht
Äh die Amerikaner kurz vor Moskau äh stehen, wenn dann irgendwie NATO Trupp so das ist sozusagen die eine.
Gut, aber es ist ja nur Propaganda.
Aber die ne diese diese Paranoia ist ist tatsächlich auch auch real.
Nennt sich dann ja Sicherheits äh äh Bedürfnisse auf amerikanischer Seite nicht ganz so ausgeprägt aber mit Monrododotrien und so.
Geht das auch durchaus durchaus in die Richtung und ja mhm.
Also.
Ich habe Atomkrieg nicht auf meiner Bingokarte, wenn ich das mal so
so sagen darf, weil ich halt einfach denke, dass es einfach klar er sieht diese Eskalationsproblem aber schon jetzt durch diese Mobilisierung steigen seine Probleme ja äh,
enorm an. So, da sind wir noch gar nicht aufm aufm aufm Schlachtfeld. Und das wird sich ja jetzt auch nicht verbessern
So und also das ist ja sozusagen absehbar, dass es alles äh ja um bei Nazi vergleichen zu bleiben in den Untergang äh führen wird.
Vor allem für für ihn und für Russland natürlich äh in gewisser Hinsicht auch.
Also irgendwann ist dann halt auch ein ein Punkt erreicht. Abgesehen davon kannst du ja mit taktischen Nuklearwaffen kein.
Erfolg erzielen. Ich meine, was will er denn da bombardieren und was soll das dann am am Ausgang ändern?
Militärisch sind die relativ nutzlos beziehungsweise nur für für ganz,
spezifische Dinge äh äh taugen halt taktische Atomwaffen nie. Äh es geht ihm dann auch gar nicht sozusagen an der Stelle dann um den militärischen,
Erfolg, sondern einfach äh das dann sagen wir Westen,
um die Welt so schockiert ist, dass man quasi so eine Auszeit nimmt. Ja, dass dann erstmal irgendwie alle sagen, okay, stopp jetzt,
ja? Äh was auch durchaus eine wahrscheinliche oder man könnte hoffentlich wahrscheinlich dann auch äh an der Stelle die die die äh Reaktion ähm.
Sein würde, aber ich ähm aber mit.
Mit diesem Commitment jetzt, also mit dieser mit dieser letzten Drohung.
Mit der Mobilmachung hat er jetzt.
Quasi klar gesagt, äh hier also entweder so das klappt jetzt oder oder ich ja, egal, was was immer nötig ist, ich werde es tun,
ja
Das ist ist im Prinzip der Punkt und ähm das war glaubwürdig, so wie er das äh ausgedrückt und formuliert hat und das ja und.
Er meinte, das ist kein Bluff.
Wenn man schon dazu sagen muss, dass es kein Bluff ist, ist es meistens einer.
Ja. Ähm wie gesagt.
Das klingt so ein bisschen so mit da steht da halt so äh ja und ich habe aber aber ich ich haue ich haue dann echt wirklich zurück, also in echt. Das ist keine Ahnung, ich kann das irgendwie nicht so richtig äh ernst nehmen, ehrlich gesagt.
Wie gesagt, das das Kalkül ist eben dann.
Äh und das ist das entspricht eben auch ja seinem seinem Verhalten
bisher, dass immer wenn er dann am Ende der Fahnenstange angekommen ist und noch eine Eskalationsmöglichkeit hat.
Dann eben auch entsprechend zu eskalieren.
Ja und erst wenn eben ganz ganz klar ähm ja ihnen Paroli geboten wird, dann halt äh,
eventuell äh ein äh zu lenken und wie gesagt, der Nutzen äh dann ist für ihn nicht nicht militärischer Art, sondern dann in erster Linie äh politischer,
Art und er glaubt halt nicht äh dass der,
wirklich bereit wäre ähm dann in dem Moment noch weiter zu eskalieren oder wirklich was tut, wenn ähm
er jetzt äh ja eine kleine taktische,
Atomwaffe, wobei es da die Debatte gibt, ob's überhaupt also Unterscheidung zwischen taktischen und strategischen Atomwaffen ist sowieso so ein bisschen,
eher künstlich. Aber ja,
Ein Eindruck ist jetzt dass äh so wie.
Wie die Figuren auf dem Brett gerade stehen und wie die.
Entscheidungslogiken gerade aussehen sozusagen der Algorithmus, der da gerade abläuft äh läuft gerade auf äh.
Atomkrieg äh hinaus.
Okay. Also äh kann ich nicht so ganz folgen, zumal ich auch den Eindruck habe, dass einfach die.
Spaltung zwischen Putin und äh der Armee dann auch äh an zu dem Zeitpunkt an an so einem.
Scheideweg angekommen ist, wo man sich fragen muss, ob die Armee überhaupt noch bereit in der Lage äh ist, seine Befehle dann auch auszuführen.
Also ob da nicht äh sozusagen auch Kräfte greifen und sagen, einfach so nächste Woche, das machen wir jetzt aber nicht, weil Untergang und äh kannst alleine untergehen und jetzt sitzen wir nicht mal wirklich ab.
Nee, diese diese äh also das wurde halt auch dann äh schon kalkuliert wahrscheinlich würden ganz viele äh äh Streitkräfte, wenn er eine.
Mir tatsächlich das nicht tun,
äh weshalb man davon ausgeht, dass wenn er diese Provokation äh durchführt äh ähm das wahrscheinlich einen einen Bomber sein wird, den er schickt mit zwei Leuten.
Also wird äh so und im Prinzip äh würde das dann so ablaufen, da wird dann eine Trainingsmission.
An äh beraumt. Da wird dann halt, das ist nicht nicht ungewöhnlich, dass die halt dann auch mit entsprechenden äh ja Sprengköpfen.
Ab und zu mal mal trainieren, ja und äh ja dann er braucht also im Grunde genommen dann nur eine Hand voll Leute, um das um dieses kleine Szenario jetzt jetzt äh umzusetzen, also insofern.
Es ja kann trotzdem sein, dass dann die zwei Leute, die dann da sitzen.
Sagen, nee, machen wir nicht, äh aber die, wie gesagt, sollten sich dann gegenseitig quasi bei der Stange halten.
Wo die Amerikaner das auch machen und äh ja dann hoffen wir natürlich, dass das dass das nicht passiert, aber.
Oder dass das irgendwie in Kürze vermieden wird und eine Möglichkeit wäre ihm dann auch
das dann irgendwann klare Ansagen von China kommen oder von
Indien äh kommen oder dann eben auch äh plötzlich der Widerstand innerhalb von äh Russland dann äh gegen Putin so stark wird, dass dieses Szenario nicht,
äh um wahr wird, aber ich ich sehe's im Moment als die wahrscheinlichste,
Tore hier gerade. Wie die Welt nimmt.
Lass uns zum Ende kommen, Pavel ähm wir blicken weiter auf die gesamte äh Situation,
Ich denke wir werden in absehbarer Zeit noch militärisch einige Bewegungen sehen und dann,
Wieder zusammentreffen und äh schauen, wie wir das alles äh bewerten.
Um den Pool leicht positiver Ausblick äh vielleicht noch ist. Also Atomkrieg in diesem Jahr nicht ist unwahrscheinlich.
Na dann. Dann ist ja.
Also nicht vor Weihnachten.
Atomkrieg nicht vor Weihnachten. Alles klar. Super. Alles klar Leute, bis bald.
Okay. So, tschüss.
Sagen tschüss.